This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. This month is all about gratitude. And you know, sometimes there's one person that we just don't thank enough, and that's ourselves. Because sometimes it's hard to remind ourselves that we are trying our best to make sense of everything in this crazy world, and it just, it's not easy. It's not, it's a lot to hold.
本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。这个月的主题是“感恩”。你知道的，有时我们总是没有对一个人表达足够的感谢，那就是我们自己。因为有时候，我们要提醒自己，在这个疯狂的世界里，我们已经尽最大努力去理解一切，这并不容易。真的不容易，要承受的实在太多了。
Listen, I think accessing gratitude is so good for your mental health. Yeah. And therapy is a great place to do that. And if you are thinking of starting therapy, you can give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. I am grateful for therapy. Yes. Let the gratitude flow with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month.
听着，我认为心怀感恩对你的心理健康大有裨益。没错。而心理咨询就是做到这一点的绝佳途径。如果你正考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行。旨在为你提供便捷、灵活、契合你日程安排的服务。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的心理咨询师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。我很感激有心理咨询。是的。让感恩通过 BetterHelp 尽情流淌吧。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com slash office ladies，首月即可享受九折优惠。
That's BetterHelp. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. The faster money and data move, the further your business can go to a seamless digital future for Canadians. Let's go faster forward together. In Life, Interact. In Life, Interact. Hi, everyone. Steve Carell here. Happy Wednesday. Angela and Jenna, my good, dear, wonderful friends, told me that they are doing a show
网址是 BetterHelp.com slash office ladies。资金和数据流动得越快，加拿大企业的业务就能向无缝的数字未来迈进得越远。让我们一起更快地向前迈进。In Life, Interact。In Life, Interact。大家好，我是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。祝大家周三愉快。安吉拉和珍娜这两个我亲爱、美好、绝妙的好朋友告诉我，她们正在做一个节目
on all things Michael Scott. So I thought I should say hello, welcome you to the show, and also congratulate the Office Ladies on Office Ladies 6.0. Let us begin with the Michael Scott episode. Enjoy. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello! Hi! How adorable is Steve Carell?
内容全是关于迈克尔·斯科特的。所以我想我应该打个招呼，欢迎你们收看这个节目，并祝贺 Office Ladies 的 Office Ladies 6.0 开播。让我们从迈克尔·斯科特这一集开始吧。尽情享受吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来终极办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量 VFF 的故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Ladies 6.0。哈喽！嗨！史蒂夫·卡瑞尔多可爱啊？
Love him. He's so sweet. Just love him. He said a special hello to everybody today. He sure did. Well, today on Office Lady 6.0, as Steve said, it's all about Michael Scott, and we got a lot of great mail from you guys on this one. I am so excited about some of the things we uncovered about Michael.
太喜欢他了。他太温柔了。就是好喜欢他。他今天特地向大家问好。他确实这么做了。好吧，在今天的 Office Ladies 6.0 里，正如史蒂夫所说，主题全关于迈克尔·斯科特，我们收到了很多你们发来的关于这集的精彩来信。对于我们发掘到的一些关于迈克尔的事情，我真是兴奋不已。
Jenna has been so secretive. Can I just tell you, she's clearly got some nugget. She won't even tell me or hint about it. And Lady, you gotta share. I will. I will. Today is the day you find out. I just have to wait.
珍娜一直守口如瓶。我能直说吗，她显然掌握了什么猛料。她甚至不肯告诉我，也不肯透露一点风声。老姐，你得分享一下啊。我会的。我会的。今天就是你揭晓答案的日子。我只是得等一下。
But first, I think we need to reveal our new format for Office Ladies 6.0. This is important. For me, it is. It is. Instead of doing fast facts, we are going to start our episodes with a top-of-show share. Jenna is very happy to ditch fast facts, y'all.
但首先，我觉得我们需要公布 Office Ladies 6.0 的全新栏目形式。这很重要。对我来说是的。确实如此。我们不再回顾“速览（fast facts）”，而是以“开场分享（top-of-show share）”来开启我们的单集。珍娜可高兴能甩掉“速览”了，各位。
I really am. But I still need my structure. You still need an outline. OK, so a top of show share can be office news, office ladies news, personal news, or a fan mail share. So there's lots of options. Today, we have office news and a fan mail share. Yeah. Why don't I start?
我真的很开心。但我还是需要我的结构。你还是需要一个大纲。好吧，所以“开场分享”可以是办公室新闻、Office Ladies 新闻、个人新闻或者粉丝来信分享。所以有很多选择。今天，我们有办公室新闻和粉丝来信分享。耶。为什么不由我先开始呢？
Do it. It's official. Office ladies is going to the paper. Yes, we are visiting Greg Daniels' new show, The Paper. We're going to be on the set, lady. They are in production right now. They have been very protective of things leaking out. Oh yeah, it's locked down. But we've been invited to visit.
开始吧。官宣了。Office Ladies 要去《The Paper》了。没错，我们要去参观格雷格·丹尼尔斯的新剧《The Paper》。我们要去片场探班，老姐。他们现在正在制作中。他们对消息泄露防范得非常严。哦，对，管控得死死的。但我们受邀去参观。
They said we could bring a little portable recording thingy. Jenna is right now with her hands motioning to her imaginary like little microphones. Yeah, I'm taking it out of my closet and I'm bringing it to the set of the paper. We're going to meet the cast. We're going to be reunited with so many of our crew. So much of our crew is working on the paper. We're gonna see Veda, our script supervisor. Kelly Cantley and Rusty Mahmood are the first ADs. Yeah. Ben Patrick is the sound mixer. And there are so many fun people from the office who have been directing episodes of the paper. Jen Salata, Ken Quapis, Jeff Blitz, Matt Sohn, and the week we're visiting, guess
他们说我们可以带个小型便携录音设备。珍娜现在正用双手对着她想象中的小话筒比划着。对，我要把它从衣橱里拿出来，带到《The Paper》的片场去。我们要去见演员阵容。我们要跟我们的许多剧组老熟人重聚。我们的剧组有好多人都在参与《The Paper》的工作。我们要见到我们的剧本总监维达。凯利·坎特利和拉斯蒂·马哈茂德是第一副导演。对。本·帕特里克是混音师。而且《办公室》里有那么多有趣的人一直在执导《The Paper》的单集。詹·萨拉塔、肯·夸皮斯、杰夫·布利茨、马特·索恩，还有我们去参观的那周，你猜
who's directing? Dave Rogers! Yes, Dave Rogers is also a co-executive producer and an editor on the show. And directing. That's triple threat right there. It sure is. And you know, Paul has been in the writers room, so we might get to see him too. I just can't wait. I'm so excited about it. I think it's gonna feel like a mini reunion. I think it's gonna be emotional. Oh, for sure.
谁在执导？戴夫·罗杰斯！没错，戴夫·罗杰斯也是该剧的联合监制兼剪辑师。还在执导。这简直是三重威胁啊。确实如此。你知道的，保罗一直在编剧室里，所以我们可能也会见到他。我简直等不及了。我对此兴奋不已。我觉得这会有一种小型重聚的感觉。我觉得这会很感人。哦，肯定的。
But I mean, we get emotional a lot over things like this. We do. How can we not? This is like our favorite thing. Well, there you have it. That's our office news. Angela? Well, my top have it. That's our office news. Angela? Well, my top of show share is inspired by this fan question from Erica H. in Portland, Oregon.
但我的意思是，我们经常为这样的事情感动。我们确实会。怎么能不呢？这就像是我们最喜欢的事。好吧，就是这样。这就是我们的办公室新闻。安吉拉？好吧，我的开头是这样的。那是我们的办公室新闻。安吉拉？好吧，我的开场分享灵感来自俄勒冈州波特兰市埃丽卡·H的粉丝提问。
Erica wrote in and said, Is there a story to the origin of Michael Scott's name? There is a Michael Scott in Dante's Inferno, and I wondered if that inspired anyone in naming the character. Oh, I love this question. I know. So I reached out to Greg Daniels. It is not from Dante's Inferno. Okay. So as you know, on the British show, the manager's name is David Brent,
埃丽卡来信说：“迈克尔·斯科特这个名字的起源有什么故事吗？但丁的《地狱》里有一个名叫迈克尔·斯科特的人，我想知道这是否启发了给这个角色取名的人？”哦，我太喜欢这个问题了。我懂。所以我联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。它并不是来自但丁的《地狱》。好吧。所以如你所知，在英国版节目中，经理的名字叫大卫·布伦特，
which is two first names. And that has become sort of a tradition in the various versions of The Office. Yeah. But I was curious, how did Greg settle on the two names, Michael and Scott? He said this, my name is almost two first names and there is something kind of lame I always felt
这是两个名。这在《办公室》的各个版本中已经成为了一种传统。是的。但我很好奇，格雷格是如何确定迈克尔和斯科特这两个名字的？他是这样说的：我的名字几乎就是两个名，而且我一直觉得，用两个名却没有姓，
in a funny way about having two first names and no last name. And Michael is a pretty generic name for our age group. There are a ton of Michaels. And I knew a guy named Scott who was kind of a derp, so I just put him together. I love the term derp, I know. I've never heard that.
从某种有趣的角度来看，有点逊。对于我们这个年龄段来说，迈克尔是一个相当大众化的名字。迈克尔多得是。我认识一个叫斯科特的家伙，有点像个二货，所以我把它们拼在了一起。我太喜欢“二货”这个词了，我知道。我从没听过。
So there you go, Erica. That is how Greg Daniels came up with the name Michael Scott. Well, my husband Lee Kirk has two first names, and I can tell you it causes him a lot of grief. We've talked about this. I texted Greg back and I said, you know, Greg, Jenna and I have talked about the fact that Lee has two first names, Lee Kirk, and Greg responded with the emoji that's the two exclamation
所以就是这样，埃丽卡。这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯想出“迈克尔·斯科特”这个名字的由来。好吧，我的丈夫李·柯克有两个名，我可以告诉你，这给他带来了很多烦恼。我们谈过这个。我给格雷格回了一条短信，我说：“你知道吗，格雷格，珍娜和我讨论过李有两个名的事，李·柯克。”格雷格回复了一个双惊叹号的表情符号。
points. I mean, I can't tell you how many dinner reservations, hotel reservations where people call him Mr. Lee. Yes. Mr. Lee welcome. Mm-hmm. We don't correct people anymore. You just go with it. We do. I know. It's like me and Kingsley. If you I'm just gonna say okay sure. Yep. Well finally we have some office ladies news. Yeah, so I guess this would be our third thing. Oh my god. We just did fast facts. We kind of did. You can't get away from it. Yeah. The hell.
我的意思是，我无法告诉你，有多少次在餐厅预订、酒店预订时，人们叫他“李先生”。是的。欢迎李先生。嗯哼。我们不再纠正别人了。你就顺其自然吧。我们确实如此。我知道。就像我和金斯利。如果你……我只会说“好吧，没问题”。是的。好吧，最后我们有一些 Office Ladies 的新闻。是的，所以我想这应该是我们的第三件事。天哪。我们刚做完“速览”。我们算做过了。你逃不掉的。对啊。见鬼。
HG double hockey sticks. Well, I can't believe it. I actually can't believe it. I okay. Well, you know what? I'm gonna just say, I bet that's not the last time you do fast facts. I'm just saying it. Why would you say that? You're saying it like, what?
双重冰球杆（HG双关语）。好吧，我真不敢相信。我真的不敢相信。好吧，你知道吗？我只想说，我敢打赌这绝对不是你最后一次做“速览”。我只是这么说说。你为什么这么说？你这话听起来就像，什么？
I want to be rid of these. I've just jinxed you. Okay. Well, we had a super fun trip. We were gonna share about it. We went up to Santa Barbara and we finally got to meet in person Kendra Adachi, the lazy genius. Yes, she was the keynote speaker at an event that weekend,
我想摆脱这些。我刚才诅咒你了。好吧，我们有一趟超级有趣的旅行。我们打算分享一下。我们去了圣巴巴拉，我们终于见到真人了——“懒惰天才”肯德拉·阿达奇。是的，她是那天周末一个活动的特邀主讲人，
but we got to have a very girly fun lunch with her. We took pictures and then Angela and I decided to stay over. We really wanted to mark the occasion of five years of office ladies with a really luxurious work trip as a reward for ourselves. We did. We treated ourselves and we also though had an amazing work session. We did.
但我们和她一起享用了非常少女、非常有趣的午餐。我们拍了照片，然后安吉拉和我决定留下来过夜。我们真的想以一次极其奢华的工作之旅来纪念 Office Ladies 五周年，以此犒劳一下自己。我们确实这么做了。我们好好犒劳了自己，不过与此同时我们也进行了一场精彩的工作会议。我们确实做了。
I mean, that's very much like us, but it was so fun from the beginning. We drove up together, Angela drove, and I did get nauseous, but it's not your fault, Ange. I really tried not to take any turns too fast. You did such a good job, but you know, with the medicines that I'm taking, they just cause a low level of baseline nausea.
我的意思是，这非常符合我们的风格，但从一开始就超级有趣。我们一起开车去的，安吉拉开车，我确实晕车了，但这可不是你的错，安吉。我真的尽量不把转弯开得太快。你做得太棒了，不过你知道的，由于我正在服用的药物，它们会引起轻微的基准恶心感。
I pretty much feel like I walk through life with like first trimester morning sickness all the time, but it gets really triggered in vehicles. You travel with your saltine crackers everywhere you go. With a sleeve of saltine crackers and ginger juice. I have to tell you, when I got back, I had to pick up the kids from school and Josh was gonna ride with me and he said,
我感觉自己走过人生的一路，都像是随时随地怀着孕初期的晨吐，但在车里这种感觉真的很容易被触发。你随身带着苏打饼干到处走。带着一包苏打饼干和生姜汁。我必须告诉你们，当我回来的时候，我得去学校接孩子们，乔希要跟我一起坐车，他说：
what happened in your passenger seat? What did you wear? There are all kinds of crops. I'm so sorry. I said, oh, I said poor Jonah ate probably a sleeve of saltine crackers in the car. I really tried not to be swervy lady. I hope I'm sorry.
“你的副驾驶座上发生了什么？你穿了什么？全都是碎屑。”太对不起了。我说：“哦，我说可怜的乔娜可能在车里吃了一包苏打饼干。”我真的尽量开车不左右晃荡，老姐。希望……我很抱歉。
You were great. You were great. But what was really cool was we went to this hotel that was on the beach, but we had booked garden rooms. But when we checked in, they upgraded us to on the beach. Jenna started to cry. I did cry. You were so excited, because we had talked about
你太棒了。你真的很棒。但真正酷的是，我们去了一家位于海滩上的酒店，但我们订的是花园房。当我们入住时，他们给我们免费升级到了海滩房。珍娜开始哭了。我确实哭了。你太兴奋了，因为我们之前讨论过
how we'd love to stay on the beach, but we're like, no, it's... It was a little extravagant. It was like pricey, and we're like, we'll just stay, and I love a garden. I love a garden nook. And then we got the upgrade and that was so fun. And I got to wake up to the ocean right there
我们多么希望能住在海滩边，但我们又觉得，不，这……这有点太奢侈了。价格有点贵，我们就想，还是住普通的吧，而且我很喜欢花园。我喜欢花园角落。然后我们得到了升级，那太有趣了。我醒来时就能看到大海就在眼前，
and we took walks on the beach and we worked and then we had a big celebration dinner that I forced us to have. I'm sorry, Angela. I love a tasting menu. She does and you guys I don't do tasting menus. I don't I mean I just don't know much about them and it was eight courses of seafood. Of seafood. And it was really good. It was really good but by the end I said I can't do it anymore. Yeah although then they wheeled
我们在海滩上散步，工作，然后我们享用了我强迫大家去吃的盛大庆祝晚宴。对不起，安吉拉。我很喜欢尝菜套餐（Tasting Menu）。她确实喜欢，各位，我可不吃尝菜套餐。我不——我的意思是，我对它们了解不多，那是八道菜的海鲜大餐。海鲜大餐。而且真的很好吃。真的很美味，但到最后我说我实在吃不下了。对，虽然接着他们推
out a cheese cart and you said I will take some of that Okay, fine. I mean you had me a cheese cart Yeah, but the coolest thing during the dinner I think was when they brought out that bread, Ange And it was this sourdough bread with a starter that was like 30 years old that the chef Travels the world travels the world with. He travels the world with his starter. You know I loved that. Your eyes about fell out of your head. And there were like flavored butters,
出了一辆奶酪车，你说：“我会来点那个的。”好吧，行吧。我的意思是，你一看到奶酪车就被拿下了。对，但我觉得晚餐期间最酷的事情是他们端出那种面包的时候，安吉。那是酸面包，用的面种有30年历史了，主厨带着它周游世界，周游世界。他带着他的面种周游世界。你知道我有多喜欢这个。你的眼珠子都快掉出来了。还有各种风味的黄油，
like a butter infused with seaweed that I wasn't sure about, but was really good. It was salty. Really, really good. But yes, anyway, we had a fantastic trip. And I want you guys to know, Kendra is the real deal. Sitting with her, having lunch with her, I felt like I had known her my whole life. She is so warm and just a delight to be around
比如我一开始不太确定、但实际上非常好吃的海苔风味黄油。咸咸的。真的非常非常美味。不过不管怎样，我们度过了一次棒极了的旅行。我想让你们知道，肯德拉是货真价实的。和她坐在一起，和她共进午餐，我觉得我仿佛认识她一辈子一样。她那么热情，和她在一起简直是一种享受，
and smart and funny. And that was such a highlight as well. And we took a bunch of pictures and videos on our work trip, which we never posted because I was nauseous for two days. And then we had no wifi. We had no wifi when we got there. And when we never posted, because I was nauseous for two days. And then we had no Wi-Fi. We had no Wi-Fi when we got there. And when we got home, I was like,
而且聪明又风趣。那也是一个巨大的亮点。我们在工作之旅中拍了好多照片和视频，但我们从来没有发过，因为我恶心了两天。然后我们那里没有无线网络。我们到达那里时没有无线网络。等我们回到家时，我觉得：
I can't look at a screen anymore. So we'll throw them up in Office Ladies Pod, finally, this week. You can check it out. Yeah. So happy five years, and happy getting to meet Kendra. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I really did a deep dive on Michael's mangled words and phrases.
我再也看不了屏幕了。所以我们本周终于会把它们发到 Office Ladies 播客上了。大家可以去看看。耶。祝五周年快乐，也祝很高兴能见到肯德拉。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？等我们回来，我真的要深入剖析迈克尔那些说错的话和词组。
It is my favorite thing about Michael Scott, and I had so much fun. And my favorite thing about Michael Scott is how much he hates technology, and I dive into that. Hey, friends. And I dive into that. Hey friends, I'm Sharon McMahon, host of Here's Where It Gets Interesting. Each week I speak with authors, experts and thought leaders on everything from American history and democracy to how to be a better person on the internet. And don't miss my extremely popular Dacu series, which educate you on things you never learned in history class. Follow and listen to Heroes Work. It's interesting
这是我关于迈克尔·斯科特最喜欢的部分，我写得太开心了。我最喜欢迈克尔·斯科特的地方是他有多讨厌科技，我会深入探讨这一点。嘿，朋友们。我会深入探讨这一点。嘿，朋友们，我是莎伦·麦克马洪，是《这才是引人入胜之处》的主持人。每周我都会与作家、专家和思想领袖对话，探讨从美国历史和民主到如何在互联网上做一个更好的人等方方面面。千万不要错过我极受欢迎的“纪实系列（Dacu series）”节目，它能让你了解你在历史课上从未学过的事物。在免费的 Odyssey 应用上或在你获取播客的任何地方，关注并收听《Heroes Work. It's interesting》吧。
on the free Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcasts. All right, we are back. Let's get started on our Michael Scott breakdown. I thought we could start by cracking open the show Bible and seeing what all we know about Michael. It's sort of a summary of Michael Scott. You just had to get a summary, didn't you? You noticed? I did notice. All right, here is your summary. Michael Gary Scott is the regional manager of Dunder Mifflin Scranton and he believes that the most important thing about a company is the people. He was born at 1123 in the morning and raised in Lackawanna County. 1123, so specific. He grew up on Kenneth Road
好了，我们回来了。让我们开始剖析迈克尔·斯科特吧。我想我们可以先翻开剧本圣经（Show Bible），看看我们对迈克尔到底了解多少。这算是对迈克尔·斯科特的一个总结。你非得弄个总结不可，对吧？你注意到了？我注意到了。好吧，这就是你的总结。迈克尔·加里·斯科特是邓德米夫林斯克兰顿分公司的地区经理，他坚信公司最重要的是人。他出生于早晨11点23分，在拉克awanna县长大。11点23分，真具体。他在肯尼斯路长大，
down the street from Chilies. He failed the first grade at least once. Prior to working at Dunder Mifflin, he worked in a fast food restaurant to save up money for business school, but he lost it in a pyramid scheme. So I guess you could say he's a little gullible because he also fell for the Nigerian Prince banking email scam and got tricked into thinking
就在奇利餐厅（Chili's）的街对面。他一年级至少留级过一次。在邓德米夫林工作之前，他在一家快餐店工作，为商学院攒学费，但他在一场传销骗局中把钱全赔了。所以我想你可以说他有点轻信于人，因为他还上过尼日利亚王子银行电子邮件诈骗的当，被骗去相信
there was a sport called poop ball. He also worked as a greeter at Men's Warehouse and invested in Blockbuster. He loves working at Dunder Mifflin, but he is not crazy about the name. He thinks it should be called something like Paper Great or Great Papers Are Passion or Super Duper Paper. Super Duper Paper's pretty great. He would love to start a restaurant called Mike's Cereal Shack
有一种运动叫“便便球（poop ball）”。他还当过男装仓库（Men's Warehouse）的迎宾员，并投资了百视达（Blockbuster）。他热爱在邓德米夫林工作，但他对这个名字不太感冒。他认为应该叫诸如“伟大纸业（Paper Great）”、“伟大纸业是激情”或“超级无敌纸业（Super Duper Paper）”之类的名字。“超级无敌纸业”挺棒的。他很想开一家餐厅叫“迈克的麦片小屋（Mike's Cereal Shack）”，
or maybe a fancy men's shoe store called Shoo La La. His heroes are Bob Hope, Abraham Lincoln, Bono and God. He claims to be part English, Irish, German, Scottish, as well as 215th Native American. Hmm. Michael enjoys improv. He really loves sugar. He has milk and sugar in the mornings. He adds sugar to his diet cola. He likes Scotch and Splenda, and his favorite drink is grenadine. That's just the red syrup that you put in a Shirley Temple. Isn't that just like a sweetener? You don't drink that by itself. Michael does. Okay. He has
或者开一家高档男士鞋店叫“Shoo La La”。他的成就是：偶像有鲍勃·霍普、亚伯拉罕·林肯、博诺和上帝。他自称有一点英国、爱尔兰、德国、苏格兰血统，还有2/15的美洲原住民血统。嗯。迈克喜欢即兴表演。他非常喜欢糖。他早上要喝牛奶加糖。他在无糖可乐里加糖。他喜欢苏格兰威士忌加代糖（Splenda），他最喜欢的饮料是红石榴糖浆（grenadine）。那不就是加在秀兰·邓波儿饮料里的红糖浆吗？那不就是个甜味剂吗？怎么会有人单独喝那个？迈克就会。好吧。据传说，
also been known to stress eat. He likes Filet-O-Fish, sausage, egg and cheese biscuits, bologna, tomato, and ketchup sub sandwiches. He orders the sweet pretzel with the 18 different toppings. He once lived on Cup of Noodles in college and he loves mint chocolate chip ice cream cake. He would actually kill himself if he was allergic to dairy. He is however- He did say that in the Alliance. He did, yeah.
他也会通过暴饮暴食来缓解压力。他喜欢菲力鱼堡（Filet-O-Fish）、香肠鸡蛋奶酪饼干、博洛尼亚红肠、西红柿番茄酱潜艇堡。他点加了18种不同配料的甜蝴蝶饼。他上大学时曾靠杯面度日，他最喜欢薄荷巧克力豆冰淇淋蛋糕。如果他对乳糖过敏，他其实会自杀的。不过他——他在《同盟（The Alliance）》里确实说过这话。他确实说过，对吧。
He says it to Meredith when they're eating cake and she's like, oh, I can't have any, I'm allergic to dairy. He is sick of Chuck E. Cheese and he is not a fan of apricots. He plays Who Would You Do all the time when he's falling asleep and he loves to wake up to the smell of bacon in the morning. He's a fan of the Pittsburgh Pirates,
他和梅里德尔吃蛋糕时对她说的，当时梅里德尔说，哦，我不能吃，我对乳糖过敏。他对查奇芝士（Chuck E. Cheese）感到厌烦，而且他不喜欢杏子。他快睡着时一直在玩“你会选谁（Who Would You Do）”的游戏，他喜欢在早晨醒来时闻到培根的香味。他是匹兹堡海盗队的球迷，
does not like the New York Mets, is a great hockey player but not good at basketball. He wears Rite Aid Nightswept cologne, which is the perfect smell-alike for Drakkar Noir. He loves a party, loves a holiday, loves to dress up as different characters. He claims to be the king of email forwards, but he doesn't really read memos. He dry cleans his jeans. He claims he can bench press 190 pounds, but also only works out with two and a half pound weights.
不喜欢纽约大都会队，是个出色的曲棍球运动员，但篮球打得不好。他用的是 Rite Aid 出品的 Nightswpt 古龙水，那是 Drakkar Noir 香水的完美平替。他热爱派对，热爱节日，喜欢扮成各种不同的角色。他自称是电子邮件转发之王，但他其实不怎么看备忘录。他干洗牛仔裤。他自称能卧推 190 磅，但也只用 2.5 磅的哑铃健身。
He's a big fan of fear factor. He's afraid of being buried alive, but his greatest fear is being alone. He would love to be part of an inside joke one day. Aw. He enjoys cuddling and spooning. He longs for a wife and children. He's good with kids.
他是《惊险大挑战（Fear factor）》的超级粉丝。他害怕被活埋，但他最大的恐惧是孤独。他渴望有一天能成为某个内部笑话的一部分。啊。他喜欢拥抱和依偎。他渴望拥有妻子和孩子。他很擅长带孩子。
He keeps a diary, has soft teeth, and has had multiple vasectomies. He eventually met the love of his life at work, Holly. They married and moved to Colorado and have two kids. Well, I just loved that. What a wonderfully like huge picture we got to see of Michael. Jenna, you must have worked so hard on that. Was that I mean, I don't know what the show Bible looks like. I haven't ever seen it. This show Bible is just lists of facts about each person. Okay. And it starts with season one, episode one,
他写日记，牙齿很软，做过多次输精管切除手术。他最终在工作中遇到了他的一生所爱——霍莉。他们结婚了，搬到了科罗拉多州，并育有两个孩子。好吧，我太喜欢这个了。我们能看到关于迈克尔如此精彩、宏大的全貌。珍娜，你一定在这上面下了苦功。那是——我的意思是，我不知道剧本圣经长什么样。我从来没见过。这本剧本圣经只是一份关于每个人的事实列表。好吧。它从第一季第一集开始，
and then it just goes through every episode. So you have to go through all the seasons for that one character and compile it all? That's what I did. Oh lady, that was a big job, thank you. You're welcome, well I had a lot of fun doing it. It was pretty cool, but yeah, I mean, I think the section of Michael Scott
然后贯穿每一集。所以你得为了那个角色翻遍所有的季节，把它们全部整理出来？我就是这么干的。哦，老姐，这可真是个大工程，谢谢你。不客气，不过我在做这个的时候玩得很开心。这真的很酷，不过，是的，我的意思是，我觉得剧本圣经里关于迈克尔·斯科特的部分，
in the show Bible is something like 14 pages long of facts about Michael Scott. Wow. You know, he also has the most episodes named after him, Michael Scott. Oh. Followed by Dwight and then Andy. So Michael has six episodes named after him and Andy and Dwight and then Andy. So Michael has six episodes named after him
足足有14页左右关于迈克尔·斯科特的事实。哇。你知道的，以他的名字命名的单集也是最多的，迈克尔·斯科特。哦。其次是德怀特，然后是安迪。所以迈克尔有六集是以他的名字命名的，安迪和德怀特各有三集。所以迈克尔有六集是以他的名字命名的，安迪和德怀特各有三集。
and Andy and Dwight have three each. That's good trivia, lady. Yeah. I should have hit you up when I made up a quiz. I made up a quiz for Michael Scott. Oh, okay. You might have covered some of it in the show Bible, but I still have a few that are gonna surprise you.
这真是个冷知识，老姐。对啊。我做那个问答测验的时候应该找你帮忙的。我为迈克尔·斯科特做了一个问答测验。哦，好吧。你可能在剧本圣经里涵盖了其中的一部分，但我还是有几个问题会让你大吃一惊。
Okay. Some deep cut Michael Scott. Well, I have a fan that are gonna surprise you. Okay. Some deep cut Michael Scott. Well, I have a fan question, Jenna, I wanted to answer from Michelle M from Berkeley. She wrote in and said, "'Where did Michael get his Dundee's? "'He created the award. "'Does this imply he also awarded one to himself? "'Which Dundee's did he receive?'
好吧。一些关于迈克尔·斯科特的冷门深度知识。好吧，我有一个粉丝提问，珍娜，我想回答来自伯克利市的米歇尔·M 的问题。她来信说：“迈克尔的邓迪奖杯是从哪里来的？是他自己创造了这个奖项。这是否意味着他也给自己颁发了一个？他到底获得过哪些邓迪奖杯？”
I have always wondered this. Well, I did some digging and I read our table read draft of the Dundee script, the shooting draft, I found some fun stuff, and then I also reached out to Greg. Poor Greg, I was just texting him like crazy. I texted Greg like crazy as well. Oh my goodness, he's going to be like, ladies, what are you doing? I literally texted, one more random question about Michael Scott. Okay, last one. So Michelle, to answer your first question,
我一直很好奇这一点。好吧，我做了一些深入挖掘，我阅读了我们《邓迪奖》剧本的围读初稿、拍摄初稿，我发现了一些有趣的东西，然后我也联系了格雷格。可怜的格雷格，我一直在疯狂地给他发短信。我给格雷格发短信也发得快疯了。哦天哪，他肯定会想：女士们，你们在干什么？我真的发了一条：“关于迈克尔·斯科特的又一个随机问题。好吧，最后一个。”所以米歇尔，为了回答你的第一个问题，
where did Michael go to get his Dundies? I found this scene in the table draft. Interior trophy shop. Michael stands at the counter of a trophy shop. He points to a Dundee man on the shelf. He says, there he is. Isn't he a handsome son of a bitch, the mythical golden dundee man. The clerk says, it's acrylic laminate. Michael says, uh-huh, perfect. Okay, I'll take 18
迈克尔去哪里买他的邓迪奖杯？我在围读剧本初稿中找到了这个场景。内景。奖杯店。迈克尔站在奖杯店的柜台前。他指着货架上的一个邓迪小金人。他说：“看呐。他不是个帅气的狗娘养的吗，神话般的金色邓迪小金人。”店员说：“这是丙烯酸树脂层压板。”迈克尔说：“呃——哼，完美。好吧，我要18个，
please. The clerk says, we have none in stock that size. I can get 18 of the larger ones. And then he shows Michael the larger ones. They're twice as big, much nicer. And Michael's like, all right, you know what? Yes, sign me up. And then the clerk says, they're $30 each. And Michael's like, okay, well, what else do you have while we're looking? Then the next scene is Michael at the register and there are a bunch of smallish trophies.
谢谢。”店员说：“我们没有那个尺寸的现货。我可以拿到18个大一点的。”然后他把大一点的展示给迈克尔看。它们大了一倍，好看得多。迈克尔就说：“好吧，你知道吗？行，算我一个。”然后店员说：“每个30美元。”迈克尔就说：“好吧，那我们看的时候你还有什么别的？”接下来的场景是迈克尔在收银台，那里有一堆小小的奖杯。
The clerk says, okay, we have six swimmers, four football players, three lacrosse girls, and five forensic plaques. That's very funny. And Michael says, gorgeous, do you take diners club? So there was a scene where he went to a trophy shop and he went looking for the Dundee's. And to answer your second question, here's what Greg had to say about how many Dundee's Michael had. He said, well, we always had one on his desk and then Jan throws one at him and in
店员说：“好吧，我们有六个游泳运动员，四个足球运动员，三个长曲棍球女孩，还有五个法医奖牌。”这太搞笑了。迈克尔说：“太华丽了，你们收大莱卡信用卡（Diners Club）吗？”所以有一个场景是他去了一家奖杯店，去找邓迪奖杯。为了回答你的第二个问题，关于迈克尔有多少个邓迪奖杯，格雷格是这么说的：他说，好吧，我们总是他的桌子上放一个，然后简朝他扔了一个，在
Shareholder meeting he does say that he's won over 17 Dundee's. The man has a lot of Dundee's so it's clear he's given himself a bunch of awards But as far as what they say, we actually don't ever see one. I mean in the beginning credits He's positioning one at the end of his desk, but the way the camera crops it, you don't see the little plaque. And then in the Dundee's episode, he holds up a few, but you can't see what's on them.
股东大会那一集里，他确实说过他赢得了17个以上的邓迪奖。这家伙有很多邓迪奖。所以很显然他自己颁发了许多奖项，但至于上面写着什么，我们实际上从来没见过一个。我的意思是，在片头字幕里，他在办公桌的尽头摆放了一个，但由于摄像机的剪裁方式，你看不到那个小牌匾。然后在《邓迪奖》那一集里，他举起了几个，但你看不清上面写着什么。
I see. But Jenna and I both just rewatched the pilot, and we both looked to see if we could see what the plaque says on the Dundee's, but the way the camera crops it, we couldn't see it. No. If someone out there saw it, let us know, but we could not see it. In fact, fan catch in the pilot, his Dundee is on his back credenza.
我明白了。但珍娜和我都刚刚重看了一遍试播集，我们都仔细看了看是否能看清邓迪奖杯牌匾上的字，但由于摄像机的剪裁方式，我们看不清。没有。如果外面的某个人看到了，请让我们知道，但我们确实看不见。事实上，试播集里的一个粉丝抓帮（fan catch）：他的邓迪奖杯在他的背部矮书柜上。
It's not on his desk. Like the opening credits. That's right. Nice, Jenna. This is when I really wish that we could reach out to Phil Shea, because I know that he did put something on each one of those plaques and he could probably tell us what it is.
不在他的办公桌上。就像片头字幕一样。没错。太棒了，珍娜。这时候我真的希望我们能联系到菲尔·希尔（Phil Shea），因为我知道他在每个牌匾上都放了东西，他大概能告诉我们那是什么。
Yeah. And so I miss you, Phil. Yeah. Well, lady, I thought we could each discuss our favorite thing about Michael Scott. Okay. We talked about this and for me, it is his tendency to mangle words and phrases.
对。所以我很想念你，菲尔。好吧，女士们，我想我们可以各自讨论一下我们最喜欢迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）的什么特点。好的。我们讨论过这个，对我来说，就是他喜欢把词语和短语说得乱七八糟的倾向。
You love this about him. I really do. The Office Alliance Facebook page posted a compilation video of Michael's mangled words and phrases. This is not complete, but it does have the greatest hits. Why don't we listen to it? Colored green.
你太爱他这一点了。我真的很喜欢。《办公室同盟》（The Office Alliance）的脸书页面发布了一个迈克尔说错词和短语的混剪视频。这虽然不完整，但确实囊括了精彩片段。我们为什么不听听呢？绿色。
It's nebulos. Those things are like ticking timebags product the progenome effort Leslie documentary and I had an epiphany early worm gets the worm Sedimentary lifestyle and escape code R. Yes, peace VT Crescent Allen that is sort of an oaky afterbirth Euthanize this place mig Migraine worker. Downloading some N3P cathartic. There's the exa-xix. Ergonomically correct.
这很模糊。那些东西就像定时炸弹，基因组测序计划，莱斯利纪录片，我突然恍然大悟。早起的鸟儿有虫吃。沉积物生活方式和逃跑代码R。是的，和平VT新月艾伦，这有点像橡木后味。安乐死这个地方，移民，偏头痛工人。下载一些N3P宣泄。就是这个。人体工程学上正确。
Improvisation. Prophilagate. It's a little hypercritical. How the turntables. I am not to be truffled with. Gotta keep yourself dehydrated. She's an anorexic. You're going to H-E-L-L double hockey sticks.
即兴创作。繁殖（应该为proliferate）。这有点吹毛求疵。风水轮流转。我可是惹不起的。得让自己保持脱水状态。她是个厌食症患者。你们要下地狱了（双冰球棍）。
He can heal leopards. A woman has you slurped my role as Santa. Contraptions! She's contrapting. We're insurmountable. You're all successories. I have your baguette. And like I'm going to believe one of his sperm lovers.
他能治愈豹子。一个女人吮吸了我的圣诞老人角色。发明！她在搞发明。我们是不可逾越的。你们都是成功者（饰品）。我有你的法棍。而且好像我会相信他其中一个精子情人一样。
A day which will live in famously. Integral to the story. We're all successories. I forgot about that one. So I think the reason why I love this so much is that initially the character of Michael Scott was based on David Brent from the British office. But this character trait is uniquely Michael. This was not something that was based on the British show. And it got me wondering, when exactly did we key in on this? Like when did this change happen?
一个遗臭万年的日子。对故事至关重要。我们都是成功者。我都忘了这个。所以我觉得我之所以这么喜欢这个，是因为最初迈克尔·斯科特这个角色是以英国版办公室的大卫·布伦特（David Brent）为原型的。但这个性格特点是迈克尔独有的。这不是基于英国版节目的设定。这让我很好奇，我们究竟是什么时候注意到这一点的？比如这个变化是什么时候发生的？
And the first time that Michael mangles a word is in the pilot. That is when he says incalculable. Mm-hmm. So I thought that was really significant because we've talked about how the pilot was basically the pilot script of the British show. But this little detail leaked in. And when we did our breakdown of the pilot, we talked a little bit about this. We said there was this talking head that was brand new to our version. Greg asked Steve to write down a list of who he thought Michael Scott would consider his heroes. And that's when he lists all the people and he goes on to talk about their contributions
迈克尔第一次说错词是在试播集里。也就是他说“不可估量（incalculable）”的时候。嗯哼。所以我觉得这非常重要，因为我们之前讨论过，试播集基本上就是英国版节目的试播剧本。但这个小细节渗透进来了。当我们剖析试播集时，我们稍微讨论了一下这个。我们说，有一个对我们的版本来说全新的访谈镜头。格雷格（Greg）让史蒂夫（Steve）写下一份名单，列出他认为迈克尔·斯科特会视为什么人为英雄的人。然后他列出了所有人，并继续谈论他们的贡献
to the world and then he said, incalculable. Well, I asked Greg about that. And he said, Steve came up with that on the day. Just on the day in one of his takes, he throws out this mangled word. And I just love this so much because I feel like we can credit Greg's collaborative spirit, Steve Carell's amazing improvisation, and it gave birth to this whole character trait. Yes, it reminds me so much of how a Post-It note led to sprinkles.
对世界的贡献，然后他说，不可估量。好吧，我问过格雷格这件事。他说，史蒂夫是当天即兴想出来的。就在拍摄当天的一次镜头中，他随口说出了这个说错的词。我太喜欢这个了，因为我觉得这要归功于格雷格的合作精神、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）惊人的即兴创作，正是这些孕育了整个角色的性格特点。是的，这太让我想起一张便利贴是如何引出喷洒（sprinkles）的了。
Right? Well, you know, eventually we started writing to this. It reminds me so much of how a Post-It note led to sprinkles, right? Well, you know, eventually we started writing to this. And I got very curious if there was someone in the writer's room who specialized in these, because they show up in so many episodes. So I did a major deep dive. Thanks to Dunderpedia, they have a list of every single word or phrase Michael has gotten wrong divided up per episode.
对吧？嗯，你知道的，最终我们开始围绕这个进行创作。这太让我想起一张便利贴是如何引出喷洒的了，对吧？嗯，你知道的，最终我们开始围绕这个进行创作。我很想知道编剧室里是否有专精于这些内容的编剧，因为它们出现在太多的剧集里了。所以我做了一次深入的深挖。感谢Dunderpedia，他们整理了一个列表，列出了迈克尔在每集里说错过所有单一词汇或短语。
Wow. In most episodes, he has one or none. But I noticed that there are a few episodes where Michael has several misused words, like three or more. And those episodes were the convention, dinner Party, Job Fair, and New Boss. Guess what all of those episodes have in common? The same writer. Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg.
哇。在大多数剧集中，他只有一个或者没有。但我注意到有几集迈克尔有好几个误用的词，比如三个或更多。那些剧集是《大会》（The Convention）、《晚宴》（Dinner Party）、《招聘会》（Job Fair）和《新老板》（New Boss）。猜猜所有这些剧集有什么共同点？同一个编剧。吉恩·斯特普尼斯基（Gene Stupnitsky）和李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）。
Huh. So I reached out to them and I was like, guys, what do I do with this? Are you guys the mangled word guys? Yeah, like Brent Forster is the pun guy. He loves the puns. Yes. Aaron Schur was our cold open fella. Right. Right. So tell me, were you the mangled word guys? And they said no. They said it was no single writer. And they said it was a combination of written lines and Steve improvisations.
哈。所以我联系了他们，我说，伙计们，我该拿这个怎么办？你们是说错词专家吗？是的，就像布伦特·福斯特（Brent Forster）是双关语专家一样。他喜欢双关语。是的。亚伦·舒尔（Aaron Schur）是我们的冷场开场专家。对的。对的。所以告诉我，你们是说错词专家吗？他们说不是。他们说这不是某个单独的编剧写的。他们说这是剧本台词和史蒂夫即兴创作的结合。
Then they told me the ones that Steve improvised in their episodes. So they said, prodigal son returns from the convention was a Steve improv, make yourself to home from dinner party was an improv, and oaky after birth was a Steve improv from dinner party. And then they said that their personal favorite mangled word, escape goat from product recall, was written by Justin Spitzer. I just love the system that we had in the office. I feel like our system of including the actors in the creation of their characters,
然后他们告诉了我史蒂夫在他们的剧集里即兴创作的内容。所以他们说，从大会归来的浪子回头是史蒂夫的即兴发挥，晚宴上的“像在家里一样自便”是即兴发挥，还有晚宴上史蒂夫即兴发挥的“橡木后味”。然后他们说他们个人最喜欢的说错词，产品召回中的“替罪羊（escape goat）”，是由贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）写的。我太喜欢我们在办公室里建立的这种体制了。我觉得我们这种将演员纳入其角色创作中的体制，
trusting us to improvise, it just led to this amazing character trait of Michael Scott that we all love. Yeah. And lady, if I could give you a dundee right now, I would give you a dundee for being the Michael Scott of Office Ladies for your mangled words. Me, Sam, and Cassie, we traded some text messages trying to remember all of the words you've mangled. So Angela, I shared my favorite and it is kid in a candy jar. Oh yes that's a classic. I love the
信任我们进行即兴创作，这恰恰成就了迈克尔·斯科特这个我们大家都爱的惊人性格特点。是的。而且，女士，如果我现在能给你颁发一个邓迪奖（Dundee），我会因为你是《办公室女士》中的迈克尔·斯科特而颁给你一个邓迪奖，因为你也总是说错词。我和萨姆（Sam）以及卡茜（Cassie）交换了一些短信，试图回忆起你所有说错过的词。所以安吉拉，我分享了我最喜欢的一个，那就是“糖果罐里的孩子（kid in a candy jar）”。哦，是的，那是经典。我喜欢
Kinsey right there. The kids inside that candy jar. Yeah, that's me. God that brings me back. The one I immediately thought of because I got it from you in a postcard on a frame is peep shot. Peep shot instead of spy shot. Yeah. And life intimidating art. Yes. Those are our favorites.
金西（Kinsey）就在这里。糖果罐里的孩子们。是的，那就是我。天哪，这勾起了我的回忆。我立刻想到的那个，因为我从你明信片的一个相框里看到的，是偷拍镜头（peep shot）。用偷拍镜头（peep shot）代替抓拍镜头（spy shot）。是的。还有生活模仿艺术（Life intimidating art）。是的。这些都是我们的最爱。
Life intimidating art might be my favorite. Kidney candy jar. I think about that once a week. That lives in your brain. Well, you know, I just spent a week with my mom. It was so wonderful and I just come by this so honest. So I wear it like a badge of honor because my mom said, are you on Twitter? I was like, no, I'm not on Twitter.
生活模仿艺术可能是我最喜欢的。糖果罐里的孩子。我一周想一次这个。这刻在你的脑海里。好吧，你知道的，我刚和妈妈呆了一周。真是太棒了，我这性格完全是遗传的。所以我把这当作一枚荣誉勋章，因为我妈说，你在推特上吗？我说，不，我不在推特上。
Really, mom? Not really. Well, maybe this is why I love this quality so much in Michael Scott is because I love it in you. Yes. I really enjoyed that so much. You know, one of the things I loved most about Michael Scott is how much he hates technology. I hate technology.
真的吗，妈妈？不是真的。好吧，也许这就是为什么我这么喜欢迈克尔·斯科特的这个特质，因为我在你身上也爱这个特质。是的。我真的很享受这个。你知道，我最喜欢迈克尔·斯科特的一点就是他有多讨厌科技。我讨厌科技。
You know, I don't want, gosh, I don't wanna go through emails and I hate it when I have to update my phone or if we get a new remote for the TV, it just pisses me off. I just want my damn old technology. I'd be so happy with a flip phone, I really would. It's true.
你知道的，我不想，天哪，我不想去查电子邮件，而且我讨厌必须更新手机，或者如果电视有了一个新遥控器，这就会惹恼我。我只想要我那该死的老科技。如果能用翻盖手机，我会非常高兴，真的。确实如此。
And I feel like Michael and I have this in common. And like you, Jenna, I found some amazing compilations that people have put together called Michael versus technology. But the clip was so long, I'm just going to share a few. He hates technology so much every single season. Well, I don't know what you're going to share, but I love when he lies about having a PowerPoint presentation ready. Well, that's't know what you're going to share, but I love when he lies about having a PowerPoint presentation ready. Well, that's one of them.
我觉得迈克尔和我在这方面很有共鸣。就像你一样，珍娜，我发现了一些人们制作的精彩合集，叫做“迈克尔大战科技”。但这个片段太长了，我只分享几个。每一季他都那么讨厌科技。好吧，我不知道你要分享什么，但我喜欢他假装自己准备好了PowerPoint演示文稿的时候。好吧，那是不知道你要分享什么，但我喜欢他假装自己准备好了PowerPoint演示文稿的时候。好吧，这是其中之一。
But before I get into all that, I have a fan question from a Joshua Snyder in Los Angeles, California. Oh, really? I know a Joshua Snyder in Los Angeles. What is his question? So do I. I told him I was doing Michael versus technology and he was very intrigued.
但在我进入所有这些之前，我有一个来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的约书亚·斯奈德（Joshua Snyder）的粉丝提问。哦，真的吗？我认识一个在洛杉矶的约书亚·斯奈德。他的问题是什么？我也认识。我告诉他我在做“迈克尔大战科技”这个主题，他非常感兴趣。
He said, ladies, I have wondered what Michael Scott would do with ChatGPT. Oh my goodness. I know. Josh said, so I asked it what the character Michael Scott would use it for and here's what it had to say. No. No.
他说，女士们，我一直想知道迈克尔·斯科特会如何使用ChatGPT。噢，天哪。我知道。乔什说，所以我问它迈克尔·斯科特这个角色会用它来做什么，它是这么回答的。不。不。
Yes. What did it say? Josh, look what he did. He did a document and everything. What would Michael Scott do with AI? This is what AI says Michael Scott would do with AI. This is very, very funny to me. These are the top 10 things. Ready? Okay. Number one, Michael would ask ridiculous questions. True. Like what is the world's best office prank, for example? Okay.
是的。它说了什么？乔什，看他做了什么。他甚至做了一个文档。迈克尔·斯科特会用人工智能做什么？这就是人工智能说迈克尔·斯科特会用人工智能做的事。我觉得这非常非常有趣。这是前10件事。准备好了吗？好的。第一，迈克尔会问荒谬的问题。真的。比如，世界上最好的办公室恶作剧是什么，举个例子？好吧。
Number two, Michael would write movie scripts. Yes. Perhaps a Michael Scarn the prequel. This is what AI said? Yes. How does AI know Michael Scott so well? I don't know. It also says his scripts would spend hours
第二，迈克尔会写电影剧本。是的。也许是迈克尔·斯卡恩前传。这是人工智能说的？是的。人工智能怎么会这么了解迈克尔·斯科特？我不知道。它还说他的剧本会花上好几个小时
detailing extravagant and nonsensical plot twists that always end with him as the hero. Wow. Number three, Michael would use it to plan office parties. They would be fun, but also professional, but mostly fun. I'm not gonna give that one to AI. I don't think Michael ever is gonna plan anything. Number four, he would use it to seek business advice. Maybe. Number five, he would use it
详述那些奢华且荒谬的情节反转，最后总是以他成为英雄而告终。哇。第三，迈克尔会用它来策划办公室派对。它们会很有趣，但也很专业，不过主要还是好玩。我可不把这个归功于人工智能。我觉得迈克尔永远不会策划任何事情。第四，他会用它来寻求商业建议。也许吧。第五，他会用它
to practice jokes. Yes. A hundred percent. And he could even say if no one was laughing, it was AI's idea, not mine. That's what AI said? Yes. AI gave Michael Scott permission to blame it? Yes. Oh my gosh. Number six, Michael would use it to get dating advice. Yes. Mm-hmm. He might ask it for some smooth pickup lines. For sure. Number seven, reinforce his ego. He might ask AI questions like, am I the world's best boss? And then look at the answers, waiting for validation. Okay. Number eight, impromptu raps. Yes.
来练习笑话。是的。百分之百。他甚至可以说，如果没人笑，那是人工智能的主意，不是我的。人工智能是这么说的？是的。人工智能给了迈克尔·斯科特责怪它的权利？是的。噢，天哪。第六，迈克尔会用它来获取约会建议。是的。嗯哼。他可能会向它讨教一些油腔滑调的搭讪台词。肯定的。第七，巩固他的自负。他可能会问人工智能一些问题，比如，我是世界上最好的老板吗？然后看着答案，等待着肯定。好的。第八，即兴说唱。是的。
Michael would use AI to help him write new versions of the Lazy Scrant rap, or to help him with his roasts at the Dundee Awards speeches. Okay. Number nine, create office training exercises. Maybe. Number 10, daydream about fame. Oh, how does AI help you daydream about fame?
迈克尔会用人工智能帮他写新版本的“懒惰斯克兰顿”说唱，或者在邓迪奖演讲中帮他写讽刺别人的台词。好的。第九，创建办公室培训练习。也许吧。第十，白日梦般地渴望名气。哦，人工智能怎么能帮你做关于名气的白日梦呢？
You know what? He could ask AI to make him the star of a movie poster or something. Well, this prompt was from AI, said Michael might say, "'How do I become a celebrity and create a list of steps to go viral so he can finally become an internet sensation? OK. AI is terrifying.
你知道吗？他可以要求人工智能让他成为电影海报的主角什么的。嗯，这个提示来自人工智能，它说迈克尔可能会说，“我该如何成为名人，并列出一份走红的步骤清单，这样他最终能成为网络红人？”好吧。人工智能太可怕了。
Well, there you go. Josh was very curious about Michael Scott and AI. And I really feel like he would have done some of those things. 100%. Okay, well now I want to start my Michael versus technology section with a clip from business school because it perfectly sums up what Michael thinks computers are for. Okay, well we can do questions. Okay, very good. First hand up. Sir, as a company that primarily distributes paper, how have you adapted your business
好了，就是这样。乔什对迈克尔·斯科特和人工智能非常好奇。我真的觉得他会做其中一些事情。百分之百。好吧，现在我想用一个来自商学院的片段来开始我的“迈克尔大战科技”板块，因为它完美地总结了迈克尔认为电脑是用来干什么的。好的，我们可以提问。好的，非常好。第一只举起的手。先生，作为一家主要分销纸张的公司，您是如何调整您的业务
model to function in an increasingly paperless world? We can't overestimate the value of computers. Yes, they are great for playing games and forwarding funny emails, but real business is done on paper, okay? Write that down. So what I love about that is he says computers
模式，以便在一个日益无纸化的世界中运作的？我们不能高估电脑的价值。是的，它们非常适合玩游戏和转发有趣的邮件，但真正的业务是在纸上完成的，好吗？把它记下来。所以这让我喜欢的一点是，他说电脑
are for games and forwarding joke emails. This is all you need to know about Michael, truly, about his work day, about what he does all day. And I was really curious when the writers first started writing this relationship of Michael with technology, it starts as early as the Alliance. So when Meredith has her birthday card and she's reading all the messages on her card, and Michael has written this lame joke about downsizing her and her age because she's getting
是用来玩游戏和转发笑话邮件的。这就是你需要了解的关于迈克尔的全部，真的，关于他的工作日，关于他一整天都在做什么。我真的很想知道编剧们是什么时候开始创作迈克尔与科技的关系的，这最早可以追溯到《同盟》那一集。当时梅雷迪思（Meredith）拿着她的生日贺卡，正在读卡片上的所有留言，而迈克尔写了一个关于缩减她规模和年龄的蹩脚笑话，因为她越来越
older, and then he says, wait, there's so many more I didn't even use, okay? And then he says, she's so old, she went into an antique store and they kept her. And he says, that wasn't even mine, I got that off the internet. So this is the first time we learn about Michael digging through the internet to get jokes. That's what he is, he's a comedian, you guys. These are his bits he's gonna do all day. So that is proof early on that he uses the internet to get jokes. Then in Hot Girl, we learn more about Michael
老了，然后他说，等等，还有好多我都没用呢，好吧？然后他说，她太老了，她去了一家古董店，结果他们把她留下了。然后他说，那甚至都不是我的，我是从网上抄的。所以这是我们第一次了解到迈克尔在网上翻找笑话。他就是这样的人，他是个喜剧演员，伙计们。这些都是他打算一整天都要表演的包袱。所以这就是早期他利用互联网获取笑话的证据。然后在《辣妹》（Hot Girl）中，我们通过两个场景了解了更多关于迈克尔
and technology in two scenes. One made it in the episode. It's when he asks Ryan if he wants to buy a purse and Ryan says, I'm installing FileShare on all the computers. And Michael goes, yeah, well, bladdy, bluddy, blah, blah, technology babble. Just do it. And then there would have been another mention
和科技的内容。一个被剪进了正片。就是他问瑞安（Ryan）是否想买一个钱包，瑞安说，我正在所有电脑上安装文件共享软件。迈克尔说，行吧，巴拉巴拉巴拉，科技废话。照做就行了。然后本应该还有另一个提及
of Michael and the internet. So there's a version of this in the deleted scenes on the DVD and in the super fan episode. But I wanna read you what was scripted in the shooting draft. Okay. Michael and Katie enter the annex. Michael points to a computer.
迈克尔和互联网的场景。所以DVD的删除片段中和超级粉丝版中都有这个版本的一个片段。但我读给你听听拍摄初稿里是怎么写的。好的。迈克尔和凯蒂（Katie）进入附属办公室。迈克尔指着一台电脑。
He looks at it and says, internet. This just made me laugh. I don't know why. He just looks at a computer and goes, Internet. Okay. Then he says, whole office is wired. Could you have imagined 10 years ago that we'd be sending messages from one side of the world
他看着它说，互联网。这真的逗笑了我。我不知道为什么。他只是看着一台电脑，然后说，互联网。好的。然后他说，整个办公室都连上网了。你能想象10年前，我们能在眨眼之间把消息从世界的一端
to the other in the blink of an eye? And Katie goes, yes. And Michael goes, 20 years ago? She doesn't say anything back. So there you have that moment, right? Then in season two, the writers really start diving into this theme of what Michael uses his computer for. I mean, there's a whole episode dedicated to email forwards. He is, as you said from the show Bible, the king of forwards. And I read
传送到另一端吗？凯蒂说，能。迈克尔说，20年前呢？她什么也没回。所以你看到了那一刻，对吧？然后在第二季，编剧们真正开始深入探讨迈克尔用电脑做什么这个主题。我的意思是，有一整集都是关于电子邮件转发的。正如你从角色圣经中所说的那样，他是转发之王。我读过
the shooting draft for sexual harassment. There was a cold open scene that starts with Michael on his computer. It's not in deleted scenes. I want to read it to you. Okay. Interior Michael's office. Michael is at his computer giggling. He gestures for the camera to come around and shoot the screen. We angle at his computer giggling. He gestures for the camera to come around and shoot the screen. We angle on his screen. It's an outlook-like email program. At least half of the emails are Michael's forwards. They have Michael Scott in all caps as the sender and subject lines like this. Forward semicolon. This is a really funny exclamation point, exclamation point, exclamation point, exclamation point,
《性骚扰》（Sexual harassment）的拍摄初稿。有一个冷场开场场景是以迈克尔在电脑前开始的。这不在删除片段里。我想读给你听。好的。内景。迈克尔的办公室。迈克尔在电脑前咯咯地笑。他示意摄像机过来拍屏幕。我们把镜头对准他的电脑，他咯咯地笑。他示意摄像机过来拍屏幕。我们把镜头对准他的屏幕。那是一个类似Outlook的电子邮件程序。至少有一半的邮件都是迈克尔转发的。发件人全大写为迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott），主题行是这样的。转发分号。这是一个非常有趣的感叹号，感叹号，感叹号，感叹号，
exclamation point A plus. Forward semicolon, top 10 reasons a beer is better than sex, B plus. And then Michael goes on to say, I rate my email forwards with a humor grade. So you know what you're getting. Important, it's very important. He says it definitely makes people
感叹号，A加。转发分号，啤酒比性更好的十大理由，B加。然后迈克尔继续说道，我用幽默等级来评价我转发的电子邮件。这样你就知道你收到的是什么了。重要，这非常重要。他说这绝对能让人
more excited to open their email. It's like how. He says it definitely makes people more excited to open their email. It's like how I like to do business. Everybody's joking around. That's how he does it. Yeah. But you would get emails that were A+, B+, some got a C grade but still sent them. Mm-hmm. And as each season goes by, there's all of these big epic technology fails for Michael. In season three he emails pictures of Jan of course to packaging at Dunder Mifflin instead of to Todd Packer and then in season four he gets a car that can talk to him. Yes it does not go well. Nope let's hear it. Everybody likes new inventions, new technology.
们更兴奋地打开他们的电子邮件。这就像我喜欢做生意的方式一样。每个人都在开玩笑。他就是这么做的。是的。但你会收到A+、B+的邮件，有些甚至得了C级但还是发了。嗯哼。随着每一季的过去，迈克尔经历了所有这些重大史诗级的科技翻车。在第三季中，他自然是把简的照片发给了邓迪米夫林的包装部门，而不是托德·帕克（Todd Packer），然后在第四季中，他得到了一辆会跟他说话的车。是的，进展很不顺利。不，让我们听听看。每个人都喜欢新发明，新技术。
People will never be replaced by machines. In the end, life and business are about human connections and computers are about trying to murder you in a lake. Oh yeah. And then as I was like researching this, every single season has so many Michael computer, internet, email, mishaps. I feel like there could be a whole book written Michael versus technology. This is just the tip of the iceberg of Michael versus technology. But I think your favorite moment is my same favorite moment. And we need to hear it. And by the way, if you watch this scene, we are both breaking. You are
人类永远不会被机器取代。说到底，生活和商业关乎人与人之间的连接，而电脑则一心想在湖里谋杀你。噢，是的。然后当我做研究时，每一季都有那么多迈克尔在电脑、互联网、电子邮件方面的糗事。我觉得可以写一本关于“迈克尔大战科技”的书。这只是“迈克尔大战科技”的冰山一角。但我认为你最喜欢的时刻也是我最喜欢的时刻。我们必须听听这个。顺便说一句，如果你看这个场景，我们两个都笑场了。你
completely like smiling through it, like not at all in character. Okay. Today we're going to be talking about PowerPoint. PowerPoint, PowerPoint, PowerPoint. Yes, I forgot about Ryan's presentation and yes it would have been nice to do well with the first presentation that he'd given me. But you know what else would have been nice? Winning the lottery. And the best way to start is to hit start and up comes the toolbar that's what she said what we have to do here is go to run and then you look up to PowerPoint and we are in we are are going to register. You hit register, updates are ready.
完全是一边笑一边演，一点也不像在角色里。好的。今天我们要讨论的是PowerPoint。PowerPoint，PowerPoint，PowerPoint。是的，我忘了瑞安的演示文稿，是的，如果能把给我的第一份演示文稿做好那就太好了。但你知道还有什么更好吗？中彩票。最好的方法就是点击开始，工具栏就会弹出来，她就是这么说的，我们这里要做的是点击运行，然后你找到PowerPoint，我们就进去了，我们要注册。你点击注册，更新已就绪。
I should update. Estimated time 12 minutes, so this should take about 5 or 10 minutes. This is the first time you've opened PowerPoint. Why? You didn't prepare a presentation at all, did you? You know what? I had a really rough night. You know what's so funny is just now playing that the part where you laughed is the same part where you break in the scene. Oh really? Yes. The part where it's like now you have to register. Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness.
我应该更新一下。预计时间12分钟，所以这应该需要大约5到10分钟。这是你第一次打开PowerPoint。为什么？你根本没有准备演示文稿，对吧？你知道吗？我昨晚过得很糟。你知道最搞笑的是，刚才播放的那部分你笑的地方，正是你在场景中笑场的地方。哦，真的吗？是的。就像现在你必须去注册的那部分。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
So I am curious why you laughed both times in the same place. Once, what, 15 years ago? Yeah. And once today, what is it about the fact that he had to then go register? Because it became so obvious he had never opened it. Correct. Like, that was the giveaway.
所以我很好奇为什么你在同一个地方笑了两次。一次是什么，15年前？是的。还有一次是今天，究竟是什么原因让他不得不去注册？因为这太明显了，他从来没打开过。对。就像，那是最大的破绽。
Like, up until that point, you could maybe believe that he thought his job was to walk you through it from the very beginning. Right. And that we're a room full of idiots. And so that's how he's giving this PowerPoint presentation. But when it's clear he never registered, you know he has put no effort into it. I mean, we all knew that he was just tap dancing his way through this anyway, but that is the moment where he's caught.
就像，直到那一刻，你或许还会相信他以为他的工作是从头到尾带你过一遍。对。而且我们是一群白痴。所以这就是他做这个PowerPoint演示文稿的方式。但当很明显他从来没有注册过时，你就知道他根本没在这上面花心思。我的意思是，我们都知道他无论如何都是在敷衍了事，但那是他当场被抓包的时刻。
Yeah, that's funny. I love that. I think I loved that. I did too. I also loved when he said, okay, now it's just going to take 12 minutes. I was the PowerPoint expert in my office when I was an administrative assistant in St. Louis, Missouri. I would make the PowerPoint presentations for all of the salespeople, for the wholesale staff. If they had to go off and meet with a client, they gave me the information they wanted,
是的，太搞笑了。我喜欢这个。我想我很喜欢这个。我也很喜欢他说，好吧，现在只需要12分钟。我在密苏里州圣路易斯市担任行政助理时，是办公室里的PowerPoint专家。我会为所有的销售人员、批发员工制作PowerPoint演示文稿。如果他们必须去见客户，他们会把他们想要的信息交给我，
and I put it into a PowerPoint for them, and I taught them how to use it. That is maybe my favorite thing that I have heard this whole month. You labeled yourself the PowerPoint expert. I was of that office and I was the youngest person in the office and I think today how, Angela, we run into this all the time
我为他们做成PowerPoint，并教他们如何使用。这可能是我这整一个月听到的最让我喜欢的事情了。你自封为PowerPoint专家。我是那个办公室的人，我是办公室里最年轻的人，现在我想想，安吉拉，我们总是遇到这种情况，
trying to post on Instagram and I don't know how to get the ratio and then the tagging and the this is very high effort for me. And then we had this babysitter over this young gal and she was like, Oh, didn't you know you can just blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I'm like, Oh, no, I did not. No, I did not know that. So I feel like that's who I was to those people in the office.
尝试在Instagram上发帖，我不知道怎么调整比例，然后是打标签和这个那个，这对我和说花费了很大的精力。然后我们请了一个年轻女孩来当临时保姆，她说，哦，难道你不知道你可以这样这样那样那样吗？我说，哦，不，我不知道。不，我真的不知道。所以我觉得我就是办公室里对那些人而言的那个人。
I was this young in who just immediately knew how to use PowerPoint and they were always so clunky with it. You were Ryan. I guess I was. I'm Michael Scott and you're Ryan. Well listen, why don't we take a break and when we come back, I did a deep dive into Michael's family of origin. Ooh, I can't wait. ["Dreams of a New World"]
我就是那个立刻就知道怎么用PowerPoint的年轻人，而他们用起来总是那么笨拙。你就是瑞安。我想我是吧。我是迈克尔·斯科特，而你是瑞安。听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我将深入探讨迈克尔的原生家庭。哦，我等不及了。["Dreams of a New World"]
All right, we are back, and before the break, we discussed everything we do know about Michael Scott, but there is one very big thing that we do not know much about, and that is his family of origin. And we got a ton of questions about Michael and his backstory. This was our fan mail flurry when we asked people to write us about Michael Scott. Here is just a sampling.
好了，我们回来了，在休息之前，我们讨论了我们所知道的关于迈克尔·斯科特的一切，但有一个非常大的事情我们所知甚少，那就是他的原生家庭。我们收到了大量关于迈克尔和他的背景故事的问题。当我们请大家写信给我们谈谈迈克尔·斯科特时，我们的粉丝来信如雪花般飞来。这里只是其中的一部分。
This one from Victoria L. in Hollis, New Hampshire, who said, I always wanted to know more about the relationship between Michael and his mother. I so wish that we could have seen at least one episode with them interacting that wasn't just a phone call. I have always wondered why there wasn't more of this relationship. Was there ever a storyline pitched where we met Michael's mom?
这封来自新罕布什尔州霍利斯的维多利亚·L（Victoria L.），她说，我一直想更多地了解迈克尔和他的母亲之间的关系。我多么希望我们能看到至少有一集他们互动的剧集，而不仅仅是一个电话。我一直很好奇为什么这种关系没有展现更多。是否曾经有过一个剧情构思，让我们见到迈克尔的妈妈？
Well, Victoria, you are correct. We do not ever meet Michael's mom. I don't even think we learn her name. I looked everywhere and I never found her name. The first time we hear from her is in season two, The Injury, Michael calls her on the phone and we hear her voice. She was played by June Squibb.
嗯，维多利亚，你说得对。我们从来没有见过迈克尔的妈妈。我想我们甚至连她的名字都不知道。我到处找过，但从来没有找到她的名字。我们第一次听到她的声音是在第二季的《受伤》（The Injury）中，迈克尔给她打电话，我们听到了她的声音。她由琼·斯奎布（June Squibb）扮演。
We also got the impression that Pam and Michael's mom talk quite often. Then in season four, Michael calls his mom from the nightclub in Night Out, and in season five, he calls and tells her he's engaged to Holly. He's not engaged to Holly. This was a thing he was doing with his mom. And then in Michael Scott Paper Company, he calls her again and says that Ryan and Pam are annoying him. So we set up that he calls his mom pretty often. And while we never ended up meeting her,
我们还觉得，帕姆和迈克的妈妈通电话的频率相当高。然后在第四季里，迈克在《夜生活》那一集里从夜总会打电话给他妈妈，而在第五季里，他打电话告诉她自己和霍莉订婚了。他根本没和霍莉订婚。这是他和妈妈玩的一个把戏。然后到了《迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司》那一集，他又打给他妈妈，说瑞安和帕姆让他很烦。所以我们能看出，他挺经常给他妈妈打电话的。虽然我们最终也没能见到她，
there was a very famous person who lobbied very hard to play Michael's mom. And you're going to be so incredibly bummed when I tell you who it is. You love this person. Wait, let me get this straight. There was an actor who would reach out and say, please can I play Michael's mom, please, please, please?
但曾有一位非常有名的大咖极力争取扮演迈克的妈妈。当我告诉你那是谁时，你一定会超级无敌沮丧的。你超爱这位演员的。等等，让我理清一下。曾经有个演员主动联系剧组，说：求求你们让我演迈克的妈妈吧，求求啦，求求啦，求求啦？
Over and over and over again. And they were like, nah, we're good? They were like, you're too famous and we don't cast famous people on our show. Is it Carol Burnett? It's Carol Burnett. Get out! Carol Burnett.
一次又一次，没完没了地求？而剧组的反应是：呃，不用了，我们挺好的？他们就好像在说：你太有名了，我们剧组不用大腕。是卡洛尔·伯内特吗？就是卡洛尔·伯内特。开玩笑吧！卡洛尔·伯内特。
Ugh! Yeah. And Greg said, if we ever did see Michael's mom, she had the role. But in early seasons, he was hesitant to cast her because she was so famous. By the way, we don't hear anything about Michael's mom in like seasons six and seven when we had broken our rule but she has given several interviews where she said I keep calling them but they keep changing their number I don't know and this was confirmed on our season four DVD commentators the writers said that if we ever meet Michael's mom Carol Burnett would play her she has volunteered for the role. Oh my gosh. I know. Carol Burnett. I know. Yeah. Maybe she could play one of our moms on Mom
天哪！对啊。格雷格说过，如果我们真要让迈克的妈妈出场，这个角色绝对非她莫属。但在前几季里，他一直对启用她有所顾虑，因为她实在太出名了。顺便说一句，到了打破常规的第六季和第七季，我们已经没怎么听到关于迈克妈妈的消息了，但她曾接受过好几次采访，说：“我一直在给他们打电话，但他们一直在换电话号码，我也不知道怎么回事。”这在我们的第四季DVD评论音轨里得到了证实，编剧们说，如果我们以后让迈克的妈妈出场，就会由卡洛尔·伯内特来扮演，她自己主动请缨要演这个角色。哦天哪。我知道。卡洛尔·伯内特。我知道。对啊。也许她可以去演我们的新剧《老妈侦探》里的某个妈妈呢。
Detectives. Yes. Maybe not the role she was looking for. She might be like, ladies, I'm good. All right. Well, that's your tidbit about Michael's mom. We also got a fan question from Stephanie M in Iowa, who said, what's the story with Michael's dad? We hear about his mom, his stepdad Jeff, and even his step half sister, his nephew. But I don't remember him ever talking about his dad. Is that ever addressed?
没错。可能不是她当年想演的那种角色吧。她大概会想：姑娘们，我挺好的，不用了。好吧，关于迈克妈妈的八卦就到这里。我们还收到了一位来自爱荷华州的粉丝斯蒂芬妮·M的提问，她说：迈克的爸爸到底是怎么回事？我们听过他妈妈、继父杰夫的事，甚至还有他同母异父的妹妹和外甥。但我记不清他谈起过他爸爸。这事儿在剧中提过吗？
Was there ever a back story to Michael? Was this discussed? Well, I traded messages with Greg Daniels who said, I know. How many texts did he get from us for this episode? Too many. So many. He said for a very long time there was a card on the wall A very long time there was a card on the wall that said Michael reunites with Dad. Oh. We just never got to it. Yeah, Greg said that we almost met Michael's dad in season seven.
迈克有过背景故事吗？大家讨论过这个吗？嗯，我跟格雷格·丹尼尔斯交换了信息，他说：我知道。为了这一集，他收到了我们多少条短信啊？太多了。多得不得了。他说，在很长的一段时间里，墙上贴着一张卡片……在很长的一段时间里，墙上贴着一张卡片，上面写着“迈克与爸爸重聚”。哦。只是我们一直没拍到那一集。对，格雷格说，我们在第七季时差点就安排迈克见他爸爸了。
That is the season where we met his nephew. You know, that's when he spanks his nephew in nepotism. Yeah. And then he has to go to counseling with Toby. Well, some of the early concepts for that episode were that Toby would draw out this really personal information from Michael about his family of origin, particularly his dad.
就是我们在那集里见到他外甥的那一季。你知道的，就是他在《裙带关系》那一集里打外甥屁股的时候。对。然后他还得跟托比一起去做心理辅导。好吧，那一集最初的一些构思是，托比会从迈克那里挖出一些非常私人的信息，关于他的原生家庭，尤其是他的爸爸。
We were going to find out that Michael only saw his dad three times a year growing up, and Toby was going to reunite Michael and his dad. The dad would come into the office, it would be a surprise, but they ended up changing it. It never happened and we never even got so far as to like put out a casting notice for the role or anything. They just pivoted. But that is the closest we got to meeting Michael's dad. And then finally in my deep dive on Michael's family of origin, I did find one moment, a story from his childhood that we shot and it was deleted.
我们本来会发现，迈克从小到大一年只能见他爸爸三次，而托比本来打算安排迈克和他的爸爸重聚。他爸爸会走进办公室，这是一个惊喜，但他们最后改了剧本。这事儿压根没发生，我们甚至都没走到为这个角色发布选角通知那一步。他们直接转换方向了。但那是我们离见到迈克爸爸最近的一次。然后最后，在我深入挖掘迈克原生家庭的过程中，我确实发现了一个瞬间，那是我们拍过的一个关于他童年的故事，但后来被删掉了。
It's a deleted scene from the surplus. This is part of the Peacock superfan episode, but I thought it would be fun to listen. I would like to tell you a little story. Let me call you right back. Okay. About a boy named... that doesn't even matter. Could be any one of you. And like any other 12 year old boy, he wanted a pippy long stocking doll for Christmas. But his evil stepfather, Jeff, said, no, you may not have what you want.
这是《盈余》一集中的删减片段。这是Peacock超级粉丝版剧集的一部分，但我觉得听一下会挺有意思的。我想给你们讲一个小故事。我马上回你电话。好的。关于一个名叫……这其实不重要。可能是你们当中的任何一个人。和任何其他12岁的小男孩一样，他圣诞节想要一个长袜子皮皮的玩偶。但他邪恶的继父杰夫说：不，你不能得到你想要的东西。
You must have a football. And the boy cried, and he cried, and he cried, and he held his breath as long as he could, and he wouldn't eat his dinner. But you know something? It turns out that Jeff was right. Because I already had a GI.I. Joe and a Stretch Armstrong and a Malibu Barbie and a Major Matt Mason,
你必须得要一个橄榄球。那个男孩哭了，哭得稀里哗啦，他屏住呼吸能憋多久就憋多久，而且他连晚饭都不肯吃。但你知道吗？事实证明，杰夫是对的。因为我已经有一个特种部队玩偶、一个大力士、一个马里布芭比和一个马特·梅森少校，
which technically is enough for a tea party. So my point is this. I didn't need what I thought I needed. What I needed was to learn how to appreciate what I had. Which in this case was enough dolls to have tea with. Exactly. Got it. So there you go, a little sad insight into his childhood. Jeff is such a dick.
严格来说，这些玩偶开个茶话会完全够了。所以我的重点是：我不需要我以为我需要的东西。我真正需要的是学会感激我所拥有的东西。在这个例子里，就是拥有足够多的玩偶来办茶话会。没错。懂了吧。所以你看，这就是关于他童年的一段略带伤感的内幕。杰夫真特么是个混蛋。
I know, I know. And you know, people were very curious if it was like a decision to keep his backstory kind of vague. But Greg said it was not. He said they pitched a lot of different stories, but they just never really took root. But after they introduced the idea of the stepdad, Jeff, that happens in season three,
我懂，我懂。而且你知道的，大家很好奇，把他的背景故事设定得这么模糊是不是剧组有意为之的决定。但格雷格说并不是。他说他们构思过很多不同的故事，但就是一直没能真正采用。不过，自从他们引入了继父杰夫这个概念后，这发生在第三季，
it sort of became part of Michael's backstory that he was basically raised by Jeff and his mom. Yeah. And so sometimes you got speeches like the one in the surplus. Right. But there wasn't much more than what we saw. There was not some like big decision they were holding back or anything like that. Well everyone we got so many questions on that topic. I really tried to deep dive that for you so I hope that was a little bit satisfying that we got a little more information about that. Yeah, I mean it still paints a pretty bleak picture for Michael growing up.
这就成了迈克背景故事的一部分：他基本上是由杰夫和妈妈抚养长大的。对。所以有时你会听到一些演讲，比如《盈余》那一集里的那段。没错。但也就只有我们在剧中看到的那些，没有更多了。并不是说他们藏着什么重大决定秘而不宣之类的。好吧，各位，我们收到了好多关于这个话题的问题。我真的试着为你们深入挖掘了一下，所以我希望我们能多了解到一些关于这方面的信息，能让大家稍微满足一点。对，我是说，这给迈克的成长经历描绘了一幅相当凄凉的画面。
Yeah. Yeah. Well you know since this is all things Michael Scott, we got a fan question that I was really curious about as well. It's from Emily V in Kansas and she says, how did the original casting call announcement describe the role of Michael Scott? Well, Emily Allison was very excited to get this question. She said, oh, Ange, I can find my notes for that. And then she gave like five exclamation points, smiley face, and here's what she wrote. She said her notes were pretty simple for the role. They said, male, age range 35 to 45,
对。对。好吧，你知道的，既然这期节目全都是关于迈克·斯科特的，我们还收到了一条我其实也很好奇的粉丝提问。它来自堪萨斯州的艾米丽·V，她说：最初的选角通告是怎么描述迈克·斯科特这个角色的？好吧，艾米丽，艾莉森对这个问题感到非常兴奋。她说：哦，安吉，我能找到我记的笔记。然后她打了大概五个感叹号加一个笑脸，这就是她写的内容。她说她关于这个角色的笔记挺简单的。上面写着：男性，年龄在35到45岁之间，
and for character description, it simply said, the manager at a small paper company, Michael is a bit of a jerk with no self-awareness. Wow. Yeah. They threw out a pretty wide net. Yeah. I always loved the little trivia
至于角色描述，简单写着：一家小型纸业公司的经理，迈克有点混蛋，毫无自我认知。哇。对。他们的选角范围撒得挺广的。对。我一直很喜欢这样一个冷知识：
that like Rainn Wilson first auditioned for Michael. Right. Because how different the part would have been if Rainn Wilson first auditioned for Michael. Right. Because how different the part would have been if Rainn played Michael. Oh yeah. Right? I mean you can only imagine him as Dwight Schrute. But what about some other people? I think about like Ben Falcone.
雷恩·威尔逊最初是为迈克这个角色试镜的。对。因为如果雷恩·威尔逊最初是为迈克试镜的，这个角色会有多大不同啊。对。因为如果雷恩演的是迈克，这个角色会有多大不同呢。哦，对啊。对吧？我是说，你只能想象他演德怀特·舒鲁特的样子。但其他人呢？我想到了像是本·法尔科内。
Auditioned for Michael. Auditioned for Michael. It's so crazy to me when you go through these audition processes and how you hone in on a character and then who ends up playing them. Because in hindsight, I can wondering what scene Jenna and Angela do you think perfectly embodies the relationship between Michael and Angela and Michael and Pam? Oh, it's such a good question. You know, one of the ones that comes to mind for me
曾为迈克试镜。曾为迈克试镜。每当我想起这些试镜过程，以及你们是如何磨合出一个角色，最后又是谁来演这个角色时，我都觉得太疯狂了。因为事后诸葛亮地来看，我在想，詹娜和安吉拉，你们觉得哪一幕最能体现迈克和安吉拉、以及迈克和帕姆之间的关系？哦，这真是个好问题。你知道，我能想到的其中一幕
is maybe not one that people would think, but it's actually in the Christmas episode where Angela's hemming Michael's pants. Okay? Because I do feel like that she like helped him with little things like that, you know? He would probably go to Angela and Pam for different things like that. And I also, of course, loved when he was heartbroken about sprinkles. He was like, oh no.
可能不是大家能想到的那种，但其实是在圣诞节那一集里，安吉拉在给迈克的裤子卷边。好吧？因为我觉得她确实会帮他处理这种小事，你知道的？他大概会为了这种琐事去找安吉拉和帕姆。而且我当然也超级喜欢当他得知小花猫“雪花”去世而心碎的那一幕。他当时说：哦不。
He was one of the people that showed true emotion about Angela's cat passing away. I mean, he did get the name wrong. But his emotion was genuine. Yeah, that's true. Well, I think for me, it would be the scene where Pam finds out that Michael is dating her mom. Yes, that's such a good scene. And the reason is because when she first comes in the office, she is like genuinely invested and excited about his personal life and his relationship.
他是对安吉拉的猫去世表现出真实情感的人之一。我是说，他确实把名字叫错了。但他的情感是真挚的。嗯，那是真的。好吧，我觉得对我来说，会是帕姆发现迈克在和她妈妈约会的那一幕。对，那一幕太精彩了。原因就在于，当她刚走进办公室时，她是真心实意地投入并为他的个人生活和恋情感到兴奋。
And you see their friendship, you see the way that they connect. And then by the end of the scene, she finds out who he is dating and she is absolutely horrified. And I just feel like that turn, that whole journey of that scene perfectly embodies the Pam Michael relationship.
你能看到他们的友谊，能看到他们建立联系的方式。然后到了这一幕的尾声，她发现了他正在约会的人是谁，她整个人震惊得无以复加。我只是觉得那种转折，那一幕整段的经历，完美地诠释了帕姆和迈克之间的关系。
It's just like a combination of horror and bonding, I guess, right? Yeah. Yeah. I love that question. Well, and you know, we also asked people to reach out to us if they had a boss like Michael Scott. We said, we want to hear about it. And we got more letters than I was expecting. A lot of people have a boss like Michael Scott. We said we want to hear about it. And we got more letters than I was
这就像是惊恐与羁绊的结合体，我猜是这样吧？对。对。我太喜欢那个问题了。好了，你知道的，我们之前还让大家跟我们联系，只要他们身边有像迈克·斯科特这样的老板。我们说：我们想听听这类的故事。结果我们收到的信比我预期的还要多。很多人都有一个像迈克·斯科特这样的老板。我们说我们想听听这类的故事。结果我们收到的信比我预期的还要多。
expecting. A lot of people have a boss like Michael Scott. I don't know if I ever shared with you that I had a coworker that was my personal Michael Scott and it was at the job that I had right before I auditioned for the office and I would imagine this person during my audition process. What were they like? They were an aspiring comedian. Oh my gosh. And my desk was right next to the like break room. Mm-hmm. And so in order to like go see what the treat of the day was or to refill your coffee, you walked right past my desk. And this guy would chat me up every day with some new pun or
很多人都有一个像迈克·斯科特这样的老板。我不知道我有没有跟你分享过，我曾有一个同事，他就是我生活中的“迈克·斯科特”，那是在我去《办公室》面试之前做的那份工作，我在面试过程中脑子里想的就是这个人。他是个什么样的人？他是个怀揣喜剧梦想的人。哦天哪。我的办公桌就在茶水间旁边。嗯哼。所以为了去看今天的点心是什么，或者去续杯咖啡，你必须从我的桌子旁走过去。这家伙每天都会跟我闲聊，讲一些新的双关语或者
some joke that I knew was probably going to be in his stand-up. And I had to do a lot of Pam-like things. You know, he wasn't my boss, but he was a superior. And so I remember that feeling of just being kind of trapped by a person. And I remember looking around the office and wondering, I wonder if another desk could become available, because I really am am I was in a high traffic area. Well you know it's the combination of comedy bits plus trapped audience. Yes
某个笑话，而我知道这些段子大概以后都会出现在他的单口喜剧里。我不得不做很多像帕姆那样的事。你知道的，他虽然不是我的老板，但他是我的上级。所以我还记得那种被一个人缠得脱不开身的感觉。我记得自己环顾办公室，心想，不知道有没有别的办公桌能空出来，因为我真的……我处在一个流量极高的区域。好吧，你知道的，这就是喜剧段子加上无法逃离的观众的组合。没错，
yes exactly. Lady this is reminding me so much of this last Southwest Airlines flight I was on. Uh-huh. Speaking of a trapped audience. Yes well the flight attendant really went for it and folks were loving it. They were cracking up. He had so many bits and I started jotting them down. I actually have them on my phone. Oh my gosh. I have to read them because I feel like I flew with the Michael Scott of flight attendants. The first one I jotted down was this one. He said, please do not open any previously purchased alcohol on this flight, save it for your mother-in-laws.
没错，太对了。天哪，这让我想起了我最近坐的这趟西南航空公司的航班。嗯哼。说到无法逃离的观众。是的，那位空乘真的太卖力了，大家都很买账。他们都笑喷了。他有太多的段子了，我开始把它们记下来。我其实把它们记在手机上了。哦天哪。我得读出来，因为我觉得我好像跟“空乘界的迈克·斯科特”一起坐过飞机。我记下的第一个段子是这个。他说：请不要在这架航班上打开任何之前买过的酒，留着给你们的岳母喝吧。
What? Then during the safety announcements, he said, parents, pick your favorite and most promising child and save that one first. Oh my gosh. Wait, then he puts on the, you know, the little life preserver thing and they talk about which thing to blow into
什么？然后在大安全须知广播期间，他说：各位父母，挑出你们最喜欢、最有出息的孩子，先把那个救上飞机。哦天哪。等等，接着他拿出了那个，你知道的，那个救生衣道具，然后他们开始讨论应该往哪个口吹气，
and what to pull. Oh no, I feel like that's what she said coming. No, there's not. Okay. He goes, please use the yellow tube to inflate and call Tom Brady to deflate. Oh boy. Oh boy, that's an old reference.
该拉哪个绳子。哦不，我感觉“她刚才就是这么说的”梗要来了。不，并没有。好吧。他说：请用黄色的管子充气，并给汤姆·布雷迪打电话来放气。哦天哪。哦天哪，这是一个老梗了。
I know, I know. Then this was a very early morning flight Oh boy, oh boy, that's an old reference. I know, I know. Then this was a very early morning flight and people wanted to nap, you know. So he says, well, we all look better with a filter, so we're going to dim the lights. So okay, then as we're about to take off, he goes, give your seatbelt a tug and your neighbor a hug. This bowing is a goin'. Wow.
我知道，我知道。然后这是一趟非常早的早班航班，哦天哪，哦天哪，这是一个老梗了。我知道，我知道。然后这是一趟非常早的早班航班，大家都想打个盹儿，你知道的。所以他说：好吧，我们化了妆开个滤镜看起来都会更好，所以我们要把机舱灯调暗。好吧，接着当我们要起飞时，他说：给你的安全带拽一拽，给你的邻居一个熊抱。这架飞机要起飞咯。哇。
Mm-hmm. And then when we landed, because we were landing in Austin, Texas, he goes, as we landed, as the wheels hit the tarmac, he goes, whoa, there Nellie, whoa. Cluck, cluck, cluck, cluck. No, he did not make clunking sounds. He did the clip clops.
嗯哼。然后当我们降落时，因为我们要降落在德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，他说，当我们降落时，当轮子触地的那一刻，他说：喔，老伙计，喔。哒哒哒哒。不，他没有发出那种沉闷的撞击声。他学的是马蹄踏地的声音。
Then he said, that bump when we landed wasn't our pilot's fault. It wasn't the flight attendant's fault. It was the ass fault. And the last thing he said was, well, welcome to Austin. Enjoy this overcast kind of scary looking day. Oh my gosh. You know what? I'm gonna say in general, I love a Southwest bit.
然后他说：我们降落时的那个颠簸不是飞行员的错。也不是空乘的错。那是沥青（asphalt，谐音ass-fault，意为“屁股的错”）的错。他说的最后一句话是：好吧，欢迎来到奥斯汀。享受这阴沉沉、看起来怪吓人的一天吧。哦天哪。你知道吗？我得说总的来说，我挺喜欢西南航空的这种小段子的。
They must encourage their flight attendants to make it fun because they usually do. That is off the charts though. That's a lot, but I am usually an enthusiastic audience on a Southwest flight. And you know what? That was Michael's philosophy. Michael's philosophy was I could give you a boring sales speech or you know this guy is like I could give you a boring safety announcement or I could make it fun. Yeah or I could be the guy that's like, click, click, click, click. Exactly. Welcome to Austin. Amazing.
他们肯定鼓励自己的空乘把航班搞得有趣一点，因为他们通常都这样。不过这也太离谱了。这戏份有点多，但在西南航空的航班上，我通常是个热情的观众。你知道吗？这就是迈克的哲学。迈克的哲学就是：我可以给你来一段枯燥的销售演讲，或者，你知道的，这家伙就好像在说：我可以给你播一段枯燥的安全须知，或者我可以把它变得妙趣横生。对，或者我可以做那个发出“哒哒哒哒”声音的人。没错。欢迎来到奥斯汀。太绝了。
All right, well, this letter is from Amelia W. in Poland, and of all the letters we received from people who said they had bosses like Michael Scott, Amelia, I think you win. Here is what Amelia said. I have a Michael-like boss. He is a good man but very distracted and here are a few of the things he has done instead of working. I love this already because this is Michael. He's like playing games on the
好吧，这封信来自波兰的艾米丽·W，在我们收到的所有自称老板像迈克·斯科特的来信中，艾米丽，我觉得你赢了。艾米丽是这么说的：我有一个像迈克一样的老板。他是个好人，但非常容易分心，以下是他在本该工作的时候做过的几件事。我一听就爱了，因为这太迈克了。他就像是在电脑上玩游戏，
computer. He's doing email forwards or he's planning a party that we don't have the budget for. Amelia said, I work in transport, just to give you some perspective. OK. But I really feel like any one of these could be an episode of The Office. Here is something Amelia's boss has done. For a whole day, he was going through different apartments
转发邮件，或者筹划一场我们根本没有预算的派对。艾米丽说：为了让你们有个概念，我是在运输行业工作。好吧。但我真的觉得这些事里的任何一件都可以拍成一集《办公室》。以下是艾米丽的老板干过的一些事。他一整天都在浏览不同的待售公寓，
for sale, commenting on every one of them, even though nobody in The Office was about to make this kind of purchase. On another day around noon, he suddenly stood up and shouted that he has to go because he left his son at school and the school is closed. Oh no. Another time he left the office without a word,
对每一套公寓评头论足，尽管办公室里根本没有人打算买这种房子。还有一天大约在中午时分，他突然站起来大喊，说他必须得走了，因为他把儿子忘在学校了，而且学校已经关门了。哦不。还有一次，他一言不发地离开办公室，
came back with the blood pressure monitor and proceeded to measure the blood pressure of every employee. That's Michael. 100%. One time he called me in his office so I could spend an hour watching him calculate my loan rate which I'm not taking for a random apartment I'm not buying. What is his obsession with apartment hunting?
回来时带了一个血压计，接着开始给每个员工量血压。这太迈克了。百分之百。有一次他把我叫进办公室，让我花了一个小时看他计算我的贷款利率——而我根本没打算贷款去买一个我并不想买的随机公寓。他到底对看房有什么执念？
I don't know. Once he found an old numerology book in a garage sale and made us listen to him telling what the day of birth meant about every person. That is definitely Michael Scott. Right? Mm-hmm. And then finally, once he wanted to cheer us up by buying pizza, but of course he picked a very bad one, and in the end of the day, I was just happy he hadn't kidnapped the delivery
我不知道。有一次他在旧货出售时找到了一本老旧的占数学书，硬要我们听他讲出生日期对每个人意味着什么。这绝对是迈克·斯科特。对吧？嗯哼。然后最后，有一次他想买披萨来让我们高兴高兴，但理所当然地，他选了一家非常难吃的店，到了那天结束时，我只庆幸他没有绑架送餐员，
boy, which is what Michael did. But those were really good. And I feel like if we ever reboot the office, Greg might want to file those away somewhere on some cards for the wall. I just want to go to Amelia's workplace just for one day. I like want to meet this guy. Yeah. Well, we also got a lot of mail about people named Michael Scott, whether people listen to them on the
而这正是迈克干过的事。但这些真的太棒了。我觉得如果我们以后重启《办公室》，格雷格可能会想把这些事归档存好，写在墙上的卡片备用。我真想去艾米丽的工作室待上一天。我简直想见见这个人。对。好吧，我们还收到了很多关于叫迈克·斯科特的人的信件，不管人们是在广播里听到他们的名字，还是在电视上看到他们当气象预报员。这个世界上确实生活着叫迈克·斯科特的人。我们对此超级好奇。所以我们联系了一位老兄，问他和一个如此著名的电视剧角色同名是一种什么体验。我要感谢迈克·斯科特·苏萨（Michael Scott Souza）跟我们聊这个。所以我问迈克，他是什么时候意识到自己和一个标志性的电视剧角色同名的？
radio or saw them as weathermen on their TVs. There are people living in the world with the name Michael Scott. We were super curious about this. So we reached out to one fella and asked him what it was like to share a name with such a famous television character. I want to say thank you to Michael Scott Souza for chatting with us about this. So I asked Michael when did he become aware that he shares a similar name to such an iconic television character?
他说这部剧开始播出的时他大概15岁，但他入坑看这部剧的时间非常晚。他直到上大学才开始看。关于迈克，这里有个小背景。他不从事纸业工作。他是一名咨询气象学家。所以我问迈克，他是什么时候意识到自己和一个标志性的电视剧角色同名
And he said the show started airing when he was around 15 years old, but he was super late into getting to know the show and watching it. He didn't start watching it until college. Here's a little something about Michael. He does not work in paper. He is a consulting meteorologist. And I asked Michael when did he become aware that he shares a similar name
的。他说他入坑这部剧的时间非常晚，直到上大学才开始看。而且他直到迈克这个角色要离开去科罗拉多时，才发现自己和对方同名。他说他Facebook页面上的每个人都在说：我们爱你，迈克·斯科特，我们爱你，迈克·斯科特，他觉得这太诡异了。他搞不懂为什么每个人都在这么说，然后他才发现他们说的是那个角色。
to such an iconic television character. He said he was super late to getting into the show and started watching in college. And he only super late to getting into the show and started watching in college and he only found out that he shared the same name when Michael, the character, was leaving for Colorado. He said everyone on his Facebook page was saying, we love you Michael Scott, we love you Michael Scott, and he said it was really strange. He didn't understand why everyone was saying this and then he found out they were talking about the character.
哦。所以他们就好像在说：再见，迈克·斯科特，我们爱你。我这是要去哪儿？你们在说什么啊？他还说，当他跟别人见面、别人听到他的名字时，会立刻问他看不看《办公室》，而且问得太频繁了，以至于他编了一个小段子来应对。哦，他开始拿这事开玩笑了。他会说：对，其实NBC曾写信给我和世界上所有其他的迈克·斯科特，请求我们授权使用我们的名字。而我答应了。然后人们会看着他说：真的吗？你认真的吗？接着他就会说：不，不，其实没有啦。
Oh. So they're like, goodbye, Michael Scott, we love you. Where am I going? What are you talking about? He also said that when he meets people and they hear his name, they immediately ask him if he watches The Office, and they ask him so frequently that he made up a little bit that he does. Oh, he started to have fun with it. He would say, yeah, NBC actually wrote to me and all the other
然后他说，大家就会相视一笑。他说，这对他结识新朋友来说是个非常好的破冰话题。不过最后，这真的把我逗乐了，他分享了一个关于这个名字如何在他的职业生活中出现的故事。所以他说他曾经把一份报告保存为“迈克·斯科特”，
Michael Scots in the world for permission to use our name. And I said, yes. And people would look at him and say, really? Are you serious? And then he'd be like, no, no, not really. And he said, they'll share a laugh. And he said, it's been a really nice icebreaker for him when he meets people. But lastly, and this just cracked me up, he shared this story about how it can pop up in his work life. So he said he once saved a report as Michael Scott,
只是为了快点命名，然后他把它发给了一个同事去核对一些事情。当这封邮件回传给他时，他们在最底部落款写着：谢谢你，德怀特·舒鲁特。哦，太可爱了。不管怎样，外面还有很多个迈克·斯科特，但我觉得看看拥有同一个名字是种什么体验真的很有意思。好吧，这让我想起了我们以前那个名叫史蒂夫·马丁（Steve Martin）的音响工程师。对。
just to name it quickly, and he sent it to a coworker to double check a few things. And when the email came back to him, they signed it at the bottom, thanks Dwight Schrute. Oh, that's cute. Anyway, there are many more Michael Scots out there, but I thought it was really fun to see what it's like to have that same name. Well, it just makes me think of our former sound engineer named Steve Martin. Yeah.
对吧？你和一个名人同名。但我从来没跟任何一个与虚构角色同名的人聊过天，这太疯狂了。对。对。好吧，詹娜，你知道的，我刚才说过我编了一个关于迈克·斯科特的测验。对。我只是想找一些可能不仅仅存在于你常规谷歌搜索中的有趣花絮，我觉得我们今天可以玩一下。萨姆、卡西，这只有五个……可能不仅仅存在于你常规谷歌搜索中的有趣花絮。我觉得我们今天可以玩一下。
Right? You share a name. That's with like a famous person but I've never talked to anybody who shares their name with a fictional character which is so crazy. Yeah. Yeah. Well Jenny you know earlier I said I made up a quiz about Michael Scott. Yes. I was just trying to find like sort of like interesting tidbits that maybe aren't just in your normal Google search and I thought we could play it today. Sam Cassie it's just five like sort of like interesting tidbits that maybe aren't just in your normal Google search. And I thought we could play it today.
萨姆、卡西，这只有五个问题。好吧。好吧。然后也许所有在听节目的听众，你们也可以跟着一起玩。你们可以对着广播大喊。我刚才是说广播吗？我不知道。对着你们的耳机。
Sam, Cassie, it's just five questions. All right. All right. And then maybe everyone listening, you guys can play along too. And you can yell at your radio. Do I say radio? I don't know. Your headphones.
你们可以把答案大喊出来，然后说：安吉拉，那个太简单了吧。天哪。好吧，第一个问题在剧集官方剧本设定集中出现过，所以你们应该都能答对，因为你们刚才才听过，萨姆、卡西。迈克用的是什么古龙水？好吧，它的味道跟“Drakkar Noir”（龙涎香/黑 Drakkar）极其相似。是的。而且它是从药妆店买的，叫“Night Swept”（夜扫/暗夜疾风）。
And you can yell at your answers out and be like, Angela, that one's so easy. Oh my gosh. Well the first one got covered in the show Bible, so you guys should all get this correct because you just heard it, Sam Cassie. What cologne does Michael wear? Well it's a perfect smell-alike for Drakkar Noir. Yes. And it is from the drug store and it is Night Swept.
叮叮叮，回答正确。它来自Rite Aid（莱德艾德药店），名字叫“Night Swept”。叮叮叮，回答正确。它来自Rite Aid，名字叫“Night Swept”。干得漂亮。我跟你们分享一下，当我看到这集时，我以为瑞安说的是“Night Sweats”（夜间盗汗），我觉得这名字起得太可怕了。我现在每天晚上都这样。那是更年期古龙水。
Ding ding ding, correct. It is from Rite Aid and it is night swept. Ding ding ding, correct. It is from Rite Aid, it is called night swept. Great job. I will share you guys when I watched it, I thought Ryan said night sweats, which I thought was a horrible name for it. That's what I do every night now. That's the menopausal cologne.
没错。好吧。我向你们保证，没人想让我喷那个。没人想要夜间盗汗。我才不要。夜间盗汗。对。好吧，第二个问题。
Exactly. Okay. I can promise you no one wants me to wear that either. No one wants night. I don't want it. Night sweats. Yeah. Okay, number two.
迈克说哪种零食是他的安慰食物？提示，我今天带了一些，我们一会儿都要尝尝。那是他的安慰食物？你刚刚谷歌了一下吗？没有。哦，真的吗？你刚才谷歌了吗？没有。哦，真的吗？你真的知道这个？是蛋黄酱配黑橄榄。
What snack does Michael say is his comfort food? Hint, I brought some today and we're all gonna try it. That is his comfort food? Did you just Google that? No. Oh yeah. Did you just Google that? No. Oh yeah. Did you seriously know that? It is mayonnaise and black olives.
安吉拉，你为什么要带这个？因为我们要尝尝。我才不吃。我要尝尝。我尝一点。谢谢你，萨姆。好吧。卡西你要尝尝吗？
Why did you bring it Angela? Because we're going to try it. I am not eating it. I am going to try it. I'll try some. Thank you Sam. All right. Are you trying some Cassie?
你不用勉强。我可不尝，因为我到现在还没从斯坦利的那块三乘五卡片（或是别的什么恶心东西）的阴影里完全恢复过来。我是绝不会吃加了橄榄的蛋黄酱的。我向你们保证。让我来告诉你们，让我告诉你们这东西看起来有多恶心。我拿了两个叉子，萨姆。哦，很好。
You do not have to. I am not trying it because I have still not completely recovered from Stanley's three by five or whatever that was. And I am not going to eat mayonnaise with olives in it. I can promise you that. Let me just tell you, let me tell you how disgusting this looks. I got two forks, Sam. Oh, good.
我们在剧里见过它吗？我是说，有那么多蛋黄酱吗？有的，因为吉姆把它误认成了冰淇淋。对。对。它看起来就像一碗冰淇淋。好了，准备好了吗？嗯哼。我只舀一点，我就舀一点这样的。
Do we ever see it in the show? Like, is it that much mayonnaise? It is because Jim mistakes it for ice cream. Yeah. Yeah. It looks like a bowl of ice cream. Okay, ready? Mm-hmm. I'm just gonna get, I'm just getting one like that.
我简直不敢相信你把它放进嘴里了。天哪。不。她刚才就是这么说的。哦，伙计们，光是看着你们我就觉得恶心。那是广告词。天哪。这怎么可能会好吃？
I can't believe you put that in your mouth. Oh my God. No. That's what she said. Oh guys, it's making me sick just looking at you. That's advertised. Oh God. Why would it be good?
你知道的，它是个有点狡猾的情人，因为有那么一个瞬间我还挺喜欢的。什么？什么瞬间？很快又不喜欢的瞬间？当它碰到你嘴里的时候？对，当时我在想：哦，蛋黄酱。然后当我吃到橄榄时，
It's, you know, it's a little tricky mistress because there was one moment I liked it. What? What moment? Quickly didn't like it. When it hit your mouth? Yeah, I was like, oh mannays. And then when I got to the olive,
我在想：好吧，我能驾驭，但紧接着更多的蛋黄酱涌上来了。对。跟我说说“狡猾的情人”这个短语。我不知道。不，我是不是刚才来了个“迈克·斯科特式”的时刻？不，我挺喜欢这种说法的。这有点像个狡猾的情人。
I was like, okay, I got this, but then more mannays came through. Yeah. Tell me about the phrase tricky mistress. I don't know. No, did I just have a Michael Scott moment? No, I like this phrasing. It's a bit of a tricky mistress.
我不知道，我刚才瞎编的。我明白了，这就好像是，哦我的……嗯，自从我喝了那杯冰茶之后，我就从尝试恶心事物的行业里退休了。哇，那真的挺恶心的。各位，这真是一个狡猾的情人。哦，太恶心了。真够恶心的。好吧，等我缓一下，我得喝点冰茶。恶心。好吧，我得喝口冰茶，等一下。第四个问题。我以为我们在第三题呢。那是第二题。抱歉，那一题榨干了我所有的精力。对，第三个问题。哦，抱歉。我刚才打了个嗝，带点蛋黄酱味儿。安吉拉，你早该把它当成第五题的。对，我为什么要把这题放在列表这么靠前的位置？
I don't know, I just made that up. I got it, it's like, oh my Um, I retired from the business of trying disgusting things after I drank that iced tea. Wow, that is pretty disgusting. It's a tricky mistress, y'all. Oh, gross. Grody gross. Okay, I gotta take some iced tea once I get. Gross. Okay, I gotta take some ice tea one second. Okay Question number four. I thought we were on number three. That was number two. Sorry that one took everything out of me. Yeah Question number three. Oh, sorry. I just burped a little bit of mayo. You should have made this number five, Angela. Yeah, why did I make that so early in my list?
好吧。第三个问题。我觉得太恶心了。我嘴里的余味太糟糕了。这东西真的把你的嘴巴裹了一层。我的整个舌头都涂上了一层厚厚的蛋黄酱。真的。好吧。
Okay. Question number three. I feel so gross. I have such a bad aftertaste. It really coats your mouth. My entire tongue is a nice mayonnaise coating. That's the truth. Okay.
为什么？迈克·斯科特的致命弱点是什么？他在《工作》那一集里透露过。这就是给你的提示。哦，他说过他的致命弱点？我想我知道。是不是他爱得太深？对，他爱得太用力了。
Why? What is Michael Scott's greatest weakness? He shares it in the job, the episode, The Job. That's your hint. Oh, he shares his greatest weakness? I think I know it. Doesn't he love too much? Yeah, he loves too hard.
差不多。哦。他工作太卖力，在乎得太多了，各位。就是这个。对，这就是他的致命弱点。好吧，第四个问题。迈克在第一季里的手机铃声是什么？《曼波第五号》（Mambo No. 5）！萨姆！对吗？萨姆！你太牛了！干得漂亮！对，不是我的
It's close. Oh. He works too hard and he cares too much, y'all. That's what it is. Yeah, that's his greatest weakness. All right, number four. What is Michael's ringtone in season one? A Mambo five? Sam! Yeah? Sam! You are crushing it! Good job. Yeah, it is not my
《Humps》（屁股）。那是后面的事。那是《分公司倒闭》那一集。第五个问题是关于迈克·斯科特的西装。好吧？好吧。神秘？对。不对，我是不是跳题了？我找到了史蒂夫穿的那套真正的西装，因为它正在被拍卖，所以我查到了是谁做的。好吧。
humps. That's later. That's in branch closing. And number five is about Michael Scott's suits. Okay? Okay. Mysterious? Yeah. No, am I jumping ahead? I found the actual suit that Steve wore because it's being auctioned off and so I found out who makes it. Okay.
但我们怎么可能知道呢？你们根本猜不到。当然不可能。也许我直接拿……汤米·希尔费格（Tommy Hilfiger）。男装仓储（Men's Wearhouse）。斯塔福德精选（Stafford Essentials）。哦！听起来是不是很高级？听起来很对。海军蓝涤纶羊毛。这下你知道了。
But how would we know? You guys aren't gonna know that. Of course not. Maybe I'll just take... Tommy Hilfiger. Men's warehouse. Stafford Essentials. Oh! Doesn't that sound fancy? That sounds right. Navy blue polyester wool. There you have it.
这就是制作迈克西装的牌子。这就是我的测验。这是我有生以来主持过的最糟糕的测验。真对不起。萨姆，你赢了。萨姆，你毫无疑问是赢家。我赢了什么？这里有一整碗没动过的……不。你赢得了一罐放在冰箱里的黑橄榄和一罐蛋黄酱。我不建议把它们混在一起吃，但也许它们单吃还行。好吧，我觉得这是给这集节目画上圆满句号的绝佳方式。
That's who makes Michael's suits. That's my quiz. That was the worst quiz I've ever been. I'm so sorry. Sam, you won. Sam, you were the clear winner. What do I win? There's an entire bowl of untouched. No. You win a can of black olives that's in the fridge and a jar of mayonnaise. I don't recommend mixing them, but maybe on their own they'll be okay. Well, I think that's a pretty great way to end this episode.
在结束前，我想分享最后这个想法。这是北卡罗来纳州的卡特·M写的一首精彩的迈克·斯科特俳句。准备好了吗？好，我是说，迈克·斯科特的俳句，来吧。毫无情商的老板，只想要一个家。他离开时我们哭了。差不多就概括了。
I would like to share this final thought before we go. It is an amazing Michael Scott Haiku from Kat M in North Carolina. Are you ready? Yes, I mean, a Michael Scott Haiku, come on. A boss with no tact who just wanted a family. We cried when he left. Kind of sums it up.
确实如此。好吧，在为这一集做研究时，网上关于迈克·斯科特的有趣内容实在是太多了。除了我们拥有的所有剧集、拍摄初稿和糖果袋备选桥段外，我太喜欢这个角色了。他简直太棒了。但我想分享一个我偶然发现的有趣事物。
Really does. Well, in doing research for this episode, there was just so much fun stuff online about Michael Scott. In addition to all of the episodes we have and shooting drafts and candy bag alts, I love this character. He's just amazing. But I wanted to share one fun thing I stumbled across.
如果你喜欢迈克桌子上的所有道具，这是一篇非常棒的文章。它的标题是：《迈克·斯科特桌面玩具收藏终极指南》。它列出了迈克桌上的所有玩具，并提供了可以购买它们的链接。哦。所以如果你想复刻你自己的迈克·斯科特办公桌，
It's a really great article if you love all the props on Michael's desk. It is titled, The Ultimate Guide to Michael Scott's Desk Toy Collection. It lists all the toys on Michael's desk and gives you a link where you can buy them. Oh. So if you wanna recreate your very own Michael Scott desk,
我会把这篇文章的链接放在快拍（Stories）里。好吧，我觉得我们可以针对迈克·斯科特的办公桌做六期节目，我会把这篇文章的链接放在快拍里。好吧，我觉得我们可以针对迈克·斯科特做六期节目。还有好多我们甚至都没来得及聊呢。我知道。但我觉得我们确实挖掘了一些关于他角色的非常有趣的新料。我真的很享受。我也是。而且我很期待为其他角色也做这样的专题。
I will put that link in stories to the article. Well, I feel like we could do six episodes on Michael Scott desk, I will put that link in stories to the article. Well, I feel like we could do six episodes on Michael Scott. There's so much we didn't even talk about. I know. But I do think we uncovered some really fun new stuff about his character. I really enjoyed this. I did too. And I'm excited to do this for other characters.
对。让我们知道下一个该做谁。我们其实不用按什么特定的顺序来，对吧？没错，不用。想做谁就做谁。她刚才就是这么说的。非常感谢史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、让·斯图普尼茨基、李·艾森伯格和罗伯·伯内特，感谢他们帮助我们获取关于迈克·斯科特的各种内幕消息。还要感谢艾利森·琼斯回答我们的问题，以及感谢迈克·斯科特·苏萨跟我们分享与迈克同名的体验。
Yeah. Let us know who should we do next. We do not have to go like in any particular order, right? Nope, we don't. Do whoever we feel like. That's what she said. A big thank you to Steve Carell, Greg Daniels, Jean Stupnitsky, Lee Eisenberg, and Rob Burnett for helping us get all the dish on Michael Scott. And thank you to Allison Jones for answering our question and to Michael Scott Souza for sharing with us about having the same name as Michael.
真的非常感谢所有写信来询问迈克·斯科特相关问题、分享他们对这个角色看法的每一个人。你们真的帮我们完成了这一集。我们太爱你们了。在结束之前，我只是想对那些跟我分享说他们要去看我的霍马克（Hallmark）圣诞电影的朋友们说声谢谢，真的。这周末吗？对，就是这个周日。
And really just a huge thank you for everyone who wrote in questions about Michael Scott, their observations about this character. You really helped us make this episode. We love you so much. And before we go, I just wanted to say thank you to people who have shared with me that they're going to watch my Hallmark Christmas movie, you guys. This weekend? Yes, it's this Sunday.
是周日晚上。请查看你当地的节目表。我觉得要么是晚上7点，要么是晚上8点，取决于你所在的地区。它叫《圣诞信件的告白》（Confessions of a Christmas Letter）。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳在里面有一个非常有趣的客串。能再次和他合作真是太棒了。而且这真的是一部非常温馨的圣诞电影。如果你看了，能艾特我一下吗？
It's Sunday evening. Check your local listings. I think it's either 7 p.m. or 8 p.m., depending on where you are. It is called Confessions of a Christmas Letter. Brian Baumgartner has a fun, fun cameo in it. It was so great to work with him again. And it's just a really sweet Christmas movie. If you watch it, will you tag me?
我想分享你们和朋友家人聚在一起看电影的画面。我们要聚在一起看。我已经迫不及待了。对啊，我们要举办一个观影派对，肯定会超级好玩。所以谢谢你们。是的，我很兴奋。好吧，那我们下周再见，
I want to share if you get together with friends and family. We're gonna get together and watch it. I can't wait. Yeah, we're having a viewing party and it's gonna be just super fun. So thank you guys. And yeah, I'm excited. All right, well, we will see you next week
我们将解析《会计师》衍生短剧（Webisodes）。别忘了，在听我们的解析之前，你可以在YouTube上观看这些短剧。当你把它们连在一起看时，大约有20分钟长。它有点像《办公室》里的一集。我们也会在快拍里放一个链接，告诉你去哪里可以观看。
when we break down the accountants webisodes. And don't forget, you can watch the webisodes on YouTube before you listen to our breakdown. And when you put them all together, it's about 20 minutes long. It's kind of like an episode of the office. We'll put a link in our stories about where you can watch it as well.
我们迫不及待地想在下周见到你们。祝大家接下来的一周过得愉快。拜拜。拜拜！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audacy呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。Audacy的执行制作人是詹娜·维斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
And we can't wait to see you next week. Have a great rest of the week. Bye. Bye. the week. Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。